thata Moffett if he's in the room his
on
[Music]
start are
these was on the phone here and I
have yeah if it's me I'm trying to turn
it
to
okay
other
rology
yeah
technology I will um I will ask for some
I know that
um staff may be tied up on the Senate
side as well so it might be a moment now
we also had computers on the desk
here is that hooked up on the floor it
looks like a lot of you in the room
aren't
muted it the the little mute sign isn't
in front of Representative mfet
representative
leakas
audio
there's option also need to turn off
your speaker if you have your speaker on
not just your microphone but your
devices
can see there we
go
lad this can you hear me if you speak
into the mic I just turned your um your
mic had come back on so I just muted
that so if you speak into the room mic
again Jette is there an echo there with
this now sounds good on my end right now
if everyone can just not move a
[Laughter]
muscle up here please um help yes I'll
go ahead uh read the Chairman's script
here first as chair of the House
Education committee I find that due to
the state of emergency Deed by the
government as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with post
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronic electronically this is a
public hearing appeals referred to the
education committee executive session
unending legislation may be held please
note that there is no fiscal location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and that the public has access
contemporaneously to listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronics calendar on the
general court website the notice up for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA
918 and anyone who has a problem
27136 or email HCS ledge. state. n. Us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Jenifer four committee researchers
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member State uh when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
Celli representative bone
here representative card here
representative Le here representa M here
representative hon here representative
Salsbury representative
L
here representative s here
representative
Miler
BL um reporting from Hopkinson with
Aussie the longair
dachon representative sh is here
representative
Cornell here I'm home and Manchester and
my husband's in the house but he's
leaving for
work representative Tanner hi I'm here
georgees Mills with my uh rescue dog
Caron is that me mellison yes I'm here
home alone in
conquered representative m in the
basement in Bedford by
myself representative
R I am home alone in uh New Hampshire at
the
moment representa
wood I'm here in C Cony with my wife and
without
represent here in my office alone but I
can't guarantee a four or fiveyear old
won't wander
no
M we we can't hear you represent Myer
are you unmuted down in the bottom
left uh what yes I responded that I'm
here in Kuka thank you oh we didn't hear
you no thank you sorry that's okay I
somewhere thank you very much Madam
clerk um so in starting today's uh
session the the hearings today we are
scheduled to start with hb214 and HB 594
FN both of these bills deal with school
building Aid I'm the prime sponsor of
hb214 and luno is the prime sponsor of
FN this is going to be a joint hearing
the way we're going to set this up is I
will introduce HB
214 I'm not going to take any questions
on 24
immediately uh reuno will introduce HB
594 FN I'm hoping he also will not take
any questions immediately we're going to
hand The Paton off to uh the director of
facilities at the Department of
Education Miss Amy Clark and then uh
representative luno and I will be
available for
questioning after we hear from the the
specialist from the Department by doing
this I believe we may have some
questions answered by the technician
there at doe and we won't be replicating
or duplicating questions later on so
with that I'm going to hand that gavl
over to to representative
cordelli become a person testifying I
did hand in my paperwork on the
computers not my paperwork but my uh
request to speak and there's a copy for
the floor thank
you thank you chairman I would like to
on4 and on of
24 chairman L for the introduction of
the Bill thank you very much uh
representative cordelli um I'm going for
the record my name is Rick blad I
represent hail Grafton for that's hail
New Hampshire not hav
ma uh for the record I will go ahead and
take portions of what I presided
presented to the clerk summary and and
then I want to hit on an area of of why
we need building Aid not necessarily
directly talking about that bill as with
all aspects of public education
including adequacy regular education CTE
Charter Schools special education
Transportation Etc corporations are
based upon dollar availability in regard
to school building a the existing
statute defines that the amount
appropriated qu shall not exceed $50
million we know that this amount is
totally inappropriate not based upon
program primarily based upon paying down
debt that at one time exceeded $540
million the if we're looking at FY 23
the debt portion of if we were to fund
at a level of $50 million would be $32
million that would leave $18 million
left for new
Renovations uh new construction of
school facilities houses throughout this
state I'll leave the rest to um either
representative uh luno or to our
specialist from the Department to to
testify that however I like to take off
and read a little bit about some of the
other aspects I think that are very
critical uh to school building
Aid there is a link between student
achievement and the condition of school
buildings scho buildings generally are
those that lack appropriate HBA systems
have poor lighting old un noisy ra
functional Furniture but have some
variation or combination of those
qualities numerous Studies have
indicated that students in po buildings
perform less well than students in
functional or acceptable
buildings research has found that
students in poor buildings older
buildings and those which are not being
pain or those that are out of date
scored between five to 10 percen rank
points lower than students and
functional buildings and that's after
controlling for socioeconomic status in
other words this issue is not just
limited to those in poverty the
difference in scores for students in
poor buildings can be as high as 177% F
points older buildings generally do not
have those elements I spoke to earlier
control of thermal environment
acceptable lighting acoustical control
and functional Furniture to compound
this issue most most of the older school
buildings and those buildings in poor
condition are located in areas of
greatest
hty lastly there is an abundance of
research that directly Associates the
health and wellness of students and
staff to the condition of school
building the US Environmental Protection
Agency has estimated that more than 10
million days of schooling are lost each
year through our country by students
with asthma attacks a study of 21,000
students found that those students in
schools were add daylighting scored 20%
higher on achievement test than students
in schools with no day lighting sixth
grade students in noisy buildings were s
years behind in Reading in those
buildings that had old science equipment
the students 8 perenti rank points for
those students using newer functional
equipment I've attempted to convey a
rationale that student School building
Aid and the costing an adequate
education are linked adequacy outcomes
are definitely influenced by school
facilities and Associated conditions New
Hampshire has an abundance of outdated
school buildings we've heard testimony
in past years from the school boards
Association School administrator
Association the doe and various folks
from various districts throughout the
state that we have over 50% of our
buildings now that are over 60 years old
we have a backload of applications in
past years we've had in the last basic
decade we've had approved four building
Aid projects of which one was an
emergency three were just recently done
I will let um Amy Park speak to that so
in conclusion this bill simply does one
thing it uh states that no less than $50
million will be appropriated for school
building Aid at this point in time the
department is is restricted from submit
submitting budgets for this that are
over $50 million by this statutory
language so the statutory language as
proposed would say no less than $50
million thank you very much for for your
time and I'll pass that baton off to
represent luno to speak to his his bill
terrific thank you very much um
representative lad and thank you very
much Mr chair um for um for the
opportunity to present House Bill
594 um in conjunction with um with house
bill um 214 so for the record my name's
David luno representing the people of
hopkington and conquered and uh and
serving on the the house education
committee um uh House Bill
594 is a p is part of a package of bills
that flow from the findings and
recommendations of the school funding
commission these bills excuse me these
bills each can stand on their own but
they also align with each other and
embrace the core values to improve
student and taxpayer equity Equity
doesn't mean equal it means Fair it's
not a one-sized fits-all solution but
one that is responsive to the needs of a
community and the resources available to
that Community House Bill 594 relates to
the school building aid program that
representative lad uh just talked about
and uh and I I I clearly uh Embrace and
endorse everything that he just um just
said um uh Hill 594 is not the
centerpiece of the commission's
recommend ation but it's a very
important piece other bills that come
from the commission's work include House
Bill 504 directed to the low and
moderate income property tax relief
program and state property tax reform
and Senate bill it's it's still in LSR
1052 which is a comprehensive Bill to
define the cost of an adequate education
and Implement a funding formula to make
sure every district has access to the
financial resources it needs to get
there like I said these bills can all
stand alone but they all work well
together too um so what I'd like to do
is walk through House Bill
594 and highlight the proposed changes
to the building aid program the changes
were developed in cooperation from the
department and Miss Clark will follow
our introductions to talk about the
building aid program and the impact
these changes would have on school
districts that have already started or
completed facility projects or have um
have projects in the pipeline so um
um so if I might just go go very quickly
um through the bill it'll only take um
hopefully a minute or two it starts very
much the same as um as House Bill 214
and is what chair lad uh talked about uh
bumping the um the the uh the funding
for building Aid up to $50 million a
year um uh in the U in both bills and in
existing statutes that's somewhat
tempered
by by any unless otherwise provided by
an act to the general court which I
interpret as the the state budget so um
so advocacy for building Aid doesn't
stop with these bills but um um but it's
important that uh that that advocacy
continue during the um during the budget
process um going on to uh page two of
the bill the um um uh 594 does change
the uh the plan design from a uh from
100% upfront to 20% of the grant upfront
and then the remaining paid over 20 year
um 20 years of equal payments and uh the
reason for this change is to tackle the
really the extensive uh project backlog
the projects that are in the pipeline a
lot of it due to the moratorium um and
uh and also recognizing that that the
state Grant doesn't cover everything on
the project so um so you know it's very
likely that that most projects are going
to require districts to go out and get a
bond anyway so uh so the 20 years of
equal payments um helps to temper the uh
the effect of um of The Debt Service on
School District budgets um another uh uh
thing that's done on page two down
towards the bottom is um is directing
the State Board to adopt rules and um
and uh and that's important important
because um the uh you know statutes are
really really to be templates for uh for
uh for Ru making and um and in the uh in
the existing statute there's there's
pages of of minutia rules which uh which
will which are which are repealed uh in
this and um uh but General guidelines
are um are are offered in 594
specifically guidelines surrounding
safety and indoor air quality so so I
think those are those are certainly
things that um um uh that need to be
considered during during project uh
planning um on page
three um uh we address some uh we we
actually address applicability of the
building aid program to projects that
were started or completed during the
moratorium years so obviously school
districts couldn't hold their breath and
tread water or tread water the whole the
whole time
while uh while while buildings required
maintenance and upgrades um uh so um uh
so you know we that it would this would
extend the um the building aid program
for a year to be able for these
districts to be able to uh to apply for
some um uh some
relief page
four um has um has a couple of um um
minor changes um uh just make sure yeah
minor changes to it um uh but but the
formula is is the same is is exactly the
same formula that the doe determines for
rating um uh or determining the uh the
grant uh that would come from the state
but it does add a reporting requirement
that I think lines up very well with
what chairman lad just uh just talked
about in terms of the um the the
correlation between student outcomes and
uh and building quality so so so this
would put some requirements on the
department to um uh to look at
improvements in buildings and look at uh
how that um U analyze how that may have
affected student outcomes in those
districts and Reporting uh those um
having those reports available to the
chairs of the uh the House and Senate
education committees um and then and
then really the last part on this on
page five um is um uh is where we we
propose to expand the grant range to
better align with the fiscal capacity
that we see U that towns and
municipalities have across our state and
um and uh with the with the chair's uh
permission and Indulgence I was
wondering if Jen could Gen 4 could um
could uh could share uh just a a sort of
a quick spreadsheet that illustrates um
the fiscal capacity range that we we see
in the
state so so thanks thanks very much Miss
Miss for um uh this is this is just a
quick spreadsheet it's based on
equalized property values from um uh
from Dr and doe data back in
fy19 um and it sorted from the lowest
property values down to the highest
property vales and I didn't plug in all
of the U the the grant determinations
uh Miss Clark is going to be talking
about that next but you can see where
you've got you've got communities that
have very low property values per pupil
like Claremont and Berlin who were under
current law getting uh getting a a 60%
uh project Grant from the state under
594 that would go up to 80% and you can
see how that also affects you know other
towns you know here on the um the the
the low side of um of equalized proper
property value per pupil so towns like
Charlestown and Newport would see um
pretty noticeable increases in um in
their their Grant eligibility from the
state um hail's in there too and um and
if we just sort of scroll down you you
can also see how how you've got property
values equalized valuations in the
400,000 500,000 600,000 so now we're
going up we're getting towns that are
starting to have a little more capacity
Franklin seasoning increase 60% to a 75%
Grant and and we keep going down here um
I wanted to put Manchester in here
because obviously that's the biggest
school district in the state 13,000 kids
almost a million dollars in um in
equalized property value they would see
an increase so now we're and we keep
keep scrolling down now we're sort of
getting into the average the state
average of equalized property value per
pupil and so and you know we all know
this because this is the this is the
property value that generates the local
property tax revenue that's used to fund
schools so now we're right at the
average here 1.1 million dollars or so
so there's probably you know not not so
much of a change in terms of the grants
that uh that these communities would be
uh would be getting for uh for building
Aid uh and we keep going so now we're
now we're into the $2 million so um and
um and now we're now we're really sort
of coming down to the to the bot of the
chart and you can see like New London um
would see its Grant reduced from 30% the
the current the current range is 30% to
60% the proposed range is 20% to 80% so
now we're seeing seeing the grant
reduced in in for some of these
municipalities that have um uh higher uh
fiscal capacity and um and you can see
you've got Molton buror and Newcastle
and Waterville Valley uh where it's
starting to go down to 25% % and then
20% for um for Newcastle which you know
has over um has over $10 million in
property value per pupil so you're
really seeing a grant range not you're
seeing really full use of a of a grant
range but you're also seeing the um the
disparity across the state in terms of
fiscal capacity and being able to raise
local tax dollars to uh to fund these
building projects I mean we started back
in you know 4505 $100,000 and now we're
looking at I mean per pupil in property
valuation and now we're looking at over
$10 million um so you know you're
getting that 5 10 20x range in um in
fiscal capacity and I'm not saying
expanding it from 20% to 60 from um 30
to 60% expanding that to 20 to
80% meets all of that need but I think
it certainly puts it in a better
Direction and um and as Miss Clark is
going toh going to lay out for us um um
you know doesn't doesn't really change
how the uh the the the total spend would
be um the total cost of the state would
be but it would be done in a more
um in a in a manner that really uh helps
to address the uh the needs and the
capacity of our of our towns so that's
what I have from um um members of the
committee thank you for your time and
and chair lad is is there anything um
you'd like to add on to
this well in regard to uh this
particular I'm not going to comment on
you know any of the you know specific
elements within however we do have a
huge disparity if you're looking at if
you looked at the next the the uh eiz
property valuations based on the
20-21 membership uh and that's ABM it's
not including
utilities um you have the lowest uh
equalized is North umberland with $
37,9
43 and then the maximum is millsfield
which has 93
m616 420 per pupil huge discrepan
discrepan discrepancies throughout the
state and this is making it very
difficult for for our
districts to come up with the bonding
levels necessary to support a bond to
take up the difference there between
what the state provides and no State
doesn't provide I'll hold any more of
these comments till um we finish with uh
Education great so uh chair lad and I
will certainly be happy to take
questions after um Miss Clark um uh
so and um Miss for we can probably um
yeah
thanks
good morning are you ready for me did
you say this is okay so uh good morning
chairman lad and committee members for
the record my name is Amy Clark and I am
the administrator for the school safety
and facility management Bureau at the
Department of Education I am I have some
handouts that I uh forwarded to you the
other day that I'm gonna going I'm going
to go over but I'm really here for any
technical assistance I'm here for you so
if you have questions or want more
information about anything I'm here to
um support that so um I think it
probably is best for me to go over my
handouts uh would you I can share my
screen if you would like would that be
helpful to folks or would you like to
will share the
screen yeah I think I have privileges so
I'm going to give it a second for it to
pop up and you let me know I got a
thumbs up that you can see it so um this
um was handed out in your email if you
um didn't get it just let me know but um
I believe that um I've heard that some
folks did so this is a 19-page document
I will not go over it all I will briefly
skim it if you want to talk about
anything specific we can always go back
and talk about it in detail um I already
spoke with you all earlier last month
and so items 1 through four in this
packet you have already seen and we've
already discussed um and items 5 through
seven are a little bit more um specific
to to this bill that I thought might be
helpful um I have a second addendum
package that uh Miss for uh forwarded to
you last night thank you so much because
I sent it to her uh after hours so I
appreciate that Jen very much and if you
haven't received it it should have been
in your inbox um
uh sometime yesterday last night so I
will go over that as well um so my
contact information is there if you ever
need
me uh this page this is page one uh well
page two and it is just the a one-page
summary of the school building aid
program it has the law is in RSA
19815 and the supporting doe regulations
are in Ed 320 1 the very Basics are
School building Aid is state aid to
support local school districts and
meeting the costs of constructing
constructing or reconstructing school
buildings I'd like to remind people that
school building Aid is for large
projects we're not talking about um re
putting in a new floor we're not talking
about redoing the roof we're talking
about a large renovation project in
order for it to qualify for building Aid
uh another thing there are not
maintenance projects
um these are actual construction large
construction
projects uh as already said the range is
30 currently 30 to 60% I'd like to just
point out that the average rate is 38% I
think that that's important especially
if you all are considering widening that
range the average rate floats around 38
to
39% um School construction the
dispersement is also important to to
note because House Bill 594 changes that
the current dispersement the way
building 8 is paid is currently uh well
prior to 2013 schools the state paid on
the term of a bond over the course of 20
years for example it depends on the term
of the bond but your Grant was paid as
the percent that you that you saw on
that list for your principal payment in
your bond it did not cover interest
payment so in the end you were still
getting that percent rate based on the
principle of your bond over that course
of the term in 2013 that was changed so
that the department only makes two
payments two instead of a payment every
year for 20 years once 2013 regulations
came into play it changed that to only
be two payments it would pay
80% of your of the district's award
upfront not an 80% award it wouldn't
cover 80% of the project what's that
saying is 80% of whatever your award was
would be paid upfront 20% upon
completion that is what the current law
states brief history again not going
over at all 1946 to
2007 uh building Aid was appropriated to
meet the demand of the applications
received in 20 2008 was the first sign
of building Aid getting a little
uncertain with funding there was a
shortfall in 2010 the state took out a
bond to cover um those obligated funds
that we had to pay on the bonds that we
were paying for the past construction
projects and officially House Bill 2
imposed a two-year moratorium on new
projects that new that two-year
moratorium um was repeated for for two
years repeatedly until the the current
bium that we're in the current bium that
we're in is the first bium fcal 20 and
21 the first bium that we have not had a
moratorium since it was in
place and again that moratorium was
prohibited the Department of Education
for funding new projects the moratorium
ended and for the first time building
Aid was funded fully in fiscal year
2020 um and in 2021 it was partially
funded uh so moving on to page three of
the handout it's real quickly just talks
about the changes that happened in 2013
in leg legis legislative changes in
2013 the key one to remember especially
for this bills these bills are that in
2013 there W wasn't a cap prior and then
in 2013 the cap um language was put in
to cap that at $50 million per year
year uh let's see again I know that
you've seen all of these before in my
prior
presentation
but um let's see can
I there we
go so this is that building Aid tail
graph um this is just something handy I
like to have all the time because people
school districts are always asking me
how much money might be available and I
start by saying well if building a is
fully funded then this fiscal 22 and
23 $32 million would be available for
new projects during the bium and I can
take you through this again but I'm
going to leave that to you to to let me
know if you want me to do this just note
here um that if you look um here is the
obligated funds or the total debt
service is 35 million for 2022
and 32 million for fiscal year
2023 those are the payments that are
paying on past projects and the state
bond that totals 35 million and 32
million for the next two years that
we're budgeting for if building Aid were
funded at 50
million then there would be 15 million
for new projects and 188 million for new
projects the second year of the vium
um you can't read this on my screen
likely magic of that I could zoom in but
really I just want you to note that
these are the project applications that
are applying for aid for fiscal 22 and
23 there are 12 projects here their
total construction costs uh their total
cost of their projects is
$270 million the state aid uh if
building Aid were funded would equate to
$104 million if all of those projects
were
funded and that's for a two-year period
so 104 let's in ball ballpark that and
just say you know that is average of 50
million for those new Pro for each year
for those projects um page
six
through
11 are um just if you want to look up
and you're curious to see oh how much um
is the state currently paying on past
projects for Interlakes well then you
can see the Department of Education is
still paying um
$115,000 to Interlakes I can see that
we're not paying them in
2023 which means that this is our last
payment and that project is going to be
one more payment and we've completed
that it's likely that that was a
probably 20 years ago that that project
started it could have had a TW 10-year
bond though so that's just an
example and scrolling through all the
way those are for all the
districts um on page 12 so this is new I
think this might be the first time that
you've seen this or in your packet um
this takes and looks at the current
building Aid rate in the current
law and Compares it to the changes made
by House Bill
594 representative luno already walked
you through some of the comparisons with
the fiscal capacity and the rates but
here it is if you want to look it up by
town but it's alphabetized by
town and at the bottom of this list is
the regional Cooperative
districts if you're looking about
districts so keep in mind that let's say
marac Valley March Valley is not a town
but it accepts students from multiple
towns so how the current law works and
there's no change to that and how it's
calculated um in the proposed law but
how that works is it's the the towns are
weighted by the number of students that
attend that school district so marac
Valley would use all the different towns
that go there Salsbury Lowden um
Penacook and so forth and so you can see
the changes in those districts um with
that last column you can see the change
in their rates
so in on page 15 of your
handout um let's see how to best look at
this one on page 15 of your handout I'd
like to stress that well this is a list
of projects that were built during the
moratorium that may have been covered by
building Aid had building Aid been
available I want to stress a couple of
things about this list this is an
informal data collection it was
collected the vast majority of this data
was collected in a survey 2016 survey
that we did um along the way we would
hear of other other schools might say oh
we just completed a project and I would
write it down and it would and it would
come into this list um this isn't a
formal application or anything like that
the um if House Bill 594 were to pass
and cover retro projects we would have
to develop a formal application uh but I
just want to note that this is not a
formal list um for
example there are some renovation
projects on here that I don't know
because I haven't seen their project
whether it would qualify for substantial
renovation which is um defined in the
law so just want to keep in mind that it
is an informal data collection um I also
want to point out that there could be
other districts that have built during
the moratorium that the state does not
know about since they don't need state
aid they don't come through my office so
I have no way of knowing how much those
projects would cost but the story of
this list is this last line and just so
that you know this an estimated list is
$530 Million worth of construction
projects that were built during the
moratorium without state aid if they had
applied for Aid using today's
rates uh the building Aid rates that
would have been1 182 million
estimated of building Aid the proposed
House Bill 594 doesn't propose to give
them that it proposes to um give a flat
rate of 20% to all those projects built
during the
moratorium another key point of this
handout is that if you were to take all
these projects I didn't actually add
them up sorry about that I don't know
how much this number is but the average
number the average project here is $1
million it might be important to kind of
scan through this list and see all these
30% um rates here as well certainly um
uh Hillsboro daring Cooperative was able
to get an A $1.2 Million uh $2 million
project pass but for the most part these
are um more affluent communities um if
that's of um interest you can see middle
Middleton also um constructed as well so
uh there's that and
then um the last part page 16 through
19 I just if this is all we really have
for facility conditions is in
2016 I conducted a Survey Monkey uh as
fancy as I got um of for schools on
their their condition of their building
um some states um do a formal needs
assessment or a condition there's
actually uh an index called a facility
condition index an FCI it's a formal
condition index um done by engineers and
um that's not what we did we did not
spend Millions we just um did a survey
so I want to point that out I sent this
to school districts I had them ask them
about their condition of their
facilities I got a fairly good response
rate for a volunteer survey of about
65% in this survey some of you have
already touched on it but um our schools
some of our schools are very old we have
6% that responded were built prior to
1900 26% of our schools that responded
to the survey were built prior than to
1950 I won't go over all of these but
the the gist is is we have some pretty
old schools out there um 60% built more
than 50 years ago and and remember this
survey is now five years old as well um
again not going to read through all of
these you have them in your handout this
one is on minimum minimum size 177%
don't say they don't meet the um
educational um minimum
requirements um 5% are using four or
more Portables I think the take-home
message here is that 85% of our schools
are not using Portables uh we would we
would see a sign of a portable as being
a temporary condition and um Portables
are not something that is that are used
for long term certainly not used for 50
years you are not using a portable
classroom or shouldn't be using a
portable classroom safety wise for for
50 years um but I just point out that
85% of our schools are not using
Portables that to me sounds like really
good news
but keep in mind that building Aid has
been funded from in the 40s all the way
through um the um in 2008 or 2010 when
the official moratorium started so
that's good you know we um moratorium
was um put in and and we have U more and
more schools that are
um that are having to put in Portables
um to cover those space
needs
um
again I won't read through all of these
this is just really um talking about
other than Portables do you have art on
a cart are you trying to use spaces that
are really not real spaces to conduct
your
education talks to that and on the
bottom of these slides you can see these
are just comments that were pulled out
in 2016 these are not my words these are
just comments in the comment section I
thought well this sort of is interesting
so I pulled it out um overall condition
of facilities these are the the school
districts reporting these facility
conditions and again you can't probably
read this slide but you might be able to
read it in your handout again these are
just comments that I thought were
interesting um so you could read through
those and that is again the school
districts reporting themselves on
whether they think they're good adequate
or
Fair um I could I'm going to stop share
and I actually have a second document to
go over that's not as
lengthy I
promise
[Music]
and um actually I need to close my
document
[Music]
first and open
apparently are you able to see this uh
see okay I'm actually sharing my sharing
this a different way for some reason it
doesn't want to come up but I can share
my screen and drag it over here so um if
I can get a thumbs up from somebody that
they can see my screen thank you very
much um this is just three pages this is
the additional handout that I um had um
sent over yesterday u based on some
questions that I thought might come up
um I figured I would throw in a couple
more slides um mostly this slide I guess
that's as big as I can get it hopefully
you have your handout or you can see
screen this is um I maybe ideally um
some states spend um a few million
dollars on um the doing A needs
assessment of what do their schools need
the state does not have a program like
that so this is a backof the envelope
calculation simply based on the current
law and statist uh numbers that we can
get like statistics
so on we have about so this is a an a
space assessment how much space does the
state have in school facilities um out
there and what might it cost to build or
rebuild these schools every 40 to 50
years so the there are
450 schools in public schools in New
Hampshire about there's about
168,000 K through 12 students note that
building Aid only covers K through 12
spaces there are of course more and more
preschool um students in schools but
building a does not cover their spaces
so if a building aid application is
received preschool is prated out of that
calculation and not covered so that's
168,000 K through 12u
students I'm going to skip a bullet um
the average cost um the average square
foot allowance in the law is 140 sare
feet per student it depends on how many
students you have bigger schools smaller
schools it depends on if your elementary
high but on average it's 140 square feet
per
student of the 12 applications received
for fiscal 22 and
23 only one school is right at that
square footage per
student uh the other all the other
schools are greater than this square
footage which means that that as local
taxpayer dollars not State Building Aid
that would cover those spaces but I just
want to make that point that special
education spaces are increasing more and
more and those square footage is not
what typically schools are building but
it is what the cap in the law is so if
you take 140 square feet per
student and you multiply that by
168,000
students you get
23.5 million square
feet so what that is essentially saying
is that the state has for State Building
Aid
purposes
23.5 million square feet to take care of
I'm not here to debate whether the state
should be taking care of it or the local
taxpayer I'll leave that to you all
legislators but I will just say that
there's 23.5 million square feet that of
public school spaces out there based on
what is allowed by the law um many
schools are closer to 200 square feet
per student we're seeing um if they have
um it also does not cover CTE spaces
because the CTE program is covered
different in a separate program so um
the average cost for a construction for
a project is about $300 a square foot um
don't use this as a state certainly
don't use this to argue with with with
your current construction project
because there are some construction
projects that are larger uh than this
$300 per square foot and some that are
that are lower than this $300 per square
foot but this is a rough average um that
that that is
so if you take $300 a square foot and
multiply it by 23.5 million square feet
billion if you assume that a school is
going to be rebuilt or have a
substantial renovation project over all
of the square footage over their
building you're looking at 100 76
million per year again not here to argue
about who pays for that I'm just here to
say that that is what the needs of an
average square footage is um if for
example the state covered on average 30%
that would equate to $53 million a year
currently the law puts their average
rate about 40% remember I said it was
like 38
39% um the the proposed changes in House
Bill 594 are right about that same range
even though it's it broadens it from 20
to 80% the average still is about the
same and it is right around 40% that
would average out to be $70 million per
year um I don't think anybody is going
to discuss today whether we should be
paying 60% of everybody's costs but if
so that would be $106 million per year I
just put those out there for numbers for
you to see um um I also just want to
make a strong note that this is for
construction and reconstruction costs
this is not maintenance costs when
typically over the life of a building
50% of your costs are for the building
itself and 50% of costs are are
maintenance of the building which means
they're equal what I'm trying to say is
they're equal your Capital costs and
your maintenance costs um are typically
the same
uh that's a nationwide um uh number
anyway on the what should be
covered so um just with that said for
example a roof a roof is a great
maintenance cost that does not covered
by building Aid it used to be a long
time ago but it is not anymore and so um
maintenance would be um not qualified
for building Aid okay so I spent a lot
of time on that slide but I don't need
to spend any time on this slide this is
just a summary of that 2016 survey um
just summarize that all those six pages
I thought was a lot so here's a summary
of what some of that says about the age
of our
buildings um odds and ends I just want
to remind you all that if you hear the
word Public School infrastructure fund
uh that is not school building Aid that
was uh $28 million of state aid for
secur mostly security projects and some
Life Safety projects and some um fiber
bringing fiber connection to schools so
that that fund expired in December of
2020 but the $28 million that um was
allocated to um security projects for
the most part CTE funding is also not
covered by school building Aid obviously
a project might have a CTE space in it
and perhaps they'll get CTE funding for
it if they're up for that funding and
those costs are actually prated out on
building Aid you can't we can't pay
building Aid on those
spaces and then lastly this does not
cover lease spaces building Aid um
specifically doesn't cost call uh pay
for lease spaces there's a separate
appropriation uh called lease Aid that
pays 30% of Charter School leases up to
$30,000 and my slide I just want to
leave you with is that that what schools
are looking for again who pays for it
I'm not I'm not sure that's up to you
all but uh what schools are looking for
they're not looking for swimming pools
they're not looking for athletic turf
fields because those are not covered by
building Aid um what the building Aid is
looking for is working HVAC systems
clean air good water quality suitable
lighting good
Acoustics uh adequate instructional
spaces accessible spaces and uh a safe
place to learn as well as a place to
play and be active for our elementary
schools so with that I know there's a
lot of
information um but that's what I have
and I'm happy to take any questions that
might um help you um make any decisions
or considerations today thank you thank
you wondering
if spond sponsors wanted to continue
their testimony based
on and
I have nothing addition my
testimony
and I I do of course have questions on
gonna
person representative do know anything
to add before we move on to
part I'm not sure uh um I'm I couldn't
hear that I don't know about the other
viewers but I couldn't hear that I think
I can hear representative lad speak but
when somebody is speaking to him I'm not
able to hear him I don't know if he
could repeat the question
Yesa you want to add your testimony
presentation
M there you
go well was that directed to me yes I I
I couldn't hear it at
Mico can you hear me now that's a lot
better thanks great thank you I just
wanted if you had any followup testimony
based on the presentation you saw I I
missed that last part
though uh did you have any followup
testimony based on Miss Clark's
presentation oh no no thank thank you
thank you very much um Mr chair for for
offering I I'm uh I I thought Miss Clark
U uh represented the the the current um
law current program as well as the
proposed uh changes uh very um
adequately great then uh we'll open up
the uh meeting questions for Miss CL
stting thank you very much Mr chair um
Miss Clark I have a question about the
20% of the building that happened during
the moratorium is that 20% of the $530
million that you shared with us we got
off I did hear the question I did hear
the question so if you all can hear me
um I think I can answer so yes I I the
way I read the bill it it looks to say
that um it doesn't Define the term of
when that is paid whether it's a it's
paid over the course of a year or many
years but the way that I read the
current law it says that I'm not the
current law the proposed House Bill 594
is that it would look to cover
20% of that 500 or more or less million
dollars of projects okay and if I may
have a followup yes you may um so that
would be approximately $106 million over
whichever time period and um sort of as
an this side do you know what a fair
interest rate would be on these Debt
Service I I would guess 3% but I'm not
exactly sure um I don't know that I
don't know the answer to that question
I'm
chair did I hear someone yeah yeah yes I
just like to um add to that to to um to
question go ahead please um the um the
594 does uh does Pro it it it's it it
certainly is still left up to the
department to determine Grant Awards so
so just because you apply doesn't mean
you get selected by the department that
would apply for projects in the pipeline
as well as um
projects that were started or completed
during the moratorium period it also as
you've pointed out representative that
it does not specify the payment plan for
those projects that receive a grant
projects that were started or completed
during the moratorium period that
received that 20% Grant and and I think
that would be subject that's a perfect
place where the department can do rul
making on that because it could be that
there's um 12 years left or 15 years
left on the um on on that District's um
um Bond payment and maybe that 20%
should be divided over 15 equal payments
to line up with that um maybe they want
it a different way um but I think that
would be U that would be subject that
would that's a good example where where
uh Department Ru making needs to have
some flexibility to deal with um um
specific needs that the districts could
have thank you follow up Sor yes if I
may follow up uh thank you very much for
that it seems like you are very familiar
with these finding mechanisms is the 3%
rate of reasonable
assumption
for I think it's a little lower than
that right now but but that's actually
one of the one of the things that that
we've added in
594 at the top of page four to um uh to
to the report reports that the that the
committee should get from the um from
the Department uh so it would have it
would talk about Bond rates um current
and anticipated so so we'd have some
better resolution of that but my
understanding is that Bond rates are are
very low right
now and um at the last followup if you
could check my assumptions here if I
take $20 million that spread over 20
years at a 3% rate that's roughly $1
million in debt service payments each
year for and then that would compound
year upon year do those numbers sound
right to you or or yeah I think I think
you're not talking about you know a
single project necessarily but um well
it could be um so so yes 20 million over
20 years with a with a compounding
well the the bond rate would be paid by
the district the state cannot take out a
bond okay so it'll be a little bit
underneath that so maybe for every $250
million the state is obligated their
obligation would be roughly a million
per year so 2 million a year obligation
for that in face 50 million so that's a
good chunk change thank you so much
thank you representative M thank you Mr
Vice chair thank you M clar for your
wonderful presentation uh I want to
point out that representative Ron uh is
a former Wall Street data analyst and
and has a seems to have a great eye for
these num numers uh and I I have a
slightly different question for Miss
Park uh very simply uh if if you can
take a minute we have some newer reps
and also some folks watching uh at home
on on YouTube if you could take just a
minute or so and explain the process for
say School Breg in any Town New
Hampshire that meets and decides they
want to apply for assistance could you
just quickly describe the pro the
process how that works in the decision
making process for how any Aid may may
granted sure happy to do that so I think
the question was that you know what what
the current process is for somebody
seeking building Aid uh and essentially
that process would be that they have to
apply so they have to apply a year or
more in advance of knowing whether
there's going to be building Aid or not
so I'm going to say that is that is a
challenge for school districts um
because they are uncertain if building
Aid is going to be funded these fiscal
22 and 23 applicants applied in
20120 and they provided a full
application to be ranked by the
Department of Education typically that
ranking is um re viewed by in December
by the School building authority the
school building authority verifies the
Department's ranking and then it's
submitted to the State Board of
Education that list is approved
typically in January of the following
just before knowing what the state
budget is so in this case it would be
January of
2021 um that process by executive order
was bumped out but that's the this the
months were bumped out but that is the
standard um what's in the current law um
their rent ranked based on a ranking is
based on lots of different criteria
could uh overcrowding school safety
issues structural issues um Ada um
Corrections that they they might be
making educational deficiencies and so
forth I don't know if that answers your
question or not that's very thank you
very much
welcome the uh further questions um from
the
committee I just have one if I might um
saw air quality list on on one your
sides is
common
renovation project and I believe Esser
one and two funds come into play
possibly with that could you explain
those funds
allocated um I think representative
cordelli I'm not sure I heard all of
your your question so I I'm going to try
to repeat it and answer it I think I
know what your question is but please
raise your hand or wave if that's not
what you wanted I think you were asking
about the Esser funds and how they might
support school facilities and indoor air
quality issues and so the SR funds I'm
not I I'm not the SR fund Grant manager
so I I I have to um defer that a little
bit I I if Caitlyn Davis is on the phone
she could probably answer that
what I can say is that um the how they
might differ from building Aid is that
the SR funding covers facility U
projects that would address indoor air
quality but I'm not familiar of how much
per school that would be and I can just
say indoor air uh uh HVAC systems are
expensive so when you're looking at s
funds HVAC systems are hundreds of
thousands of dollars depending on the
square footage of a building all the way
up to a million plus dollars so um I
guess it would depend on the Esser funds
what they need them for and whether
they're apply but you are correct the SR
funds do have a criteria in them that
says that facilities can cover those
projects and I saw Caitlyn Davis's uh
face pop up but I'll turn that back over
to you representative lad sorry in
there you like to follow on question
sure um
so there is a lot of flexibility with
the SR 2 fund as opposed to the Sesser
One Fund which was distributed um in the
spring of 2020 sr2 was received by the
Department of Education about three
weeks ago the Department of Education
put out preliminary allocations to
school districts on Friday um however
they have not been finalized and they
were in the process of being distributed
by the department there is certainly
some flexibility that um Air Quality
Systems could be an allowable use of
those funds however um you know it's
kind of limited by the amount of funds
that a certain School District receives
um some some school districts received
only a few hundred dollars even under
sr2 which is a new $140 million package
some school districts like Manchester
received or are going to receive an
estimated $26 million so they are
semi-limited by the availability of the
funds um the
issue is I mean there's some fairly
complex construction standards that
school districts will be required to
follow if they choose to build um any
sort of um air quality system or
anything like that so um these are
actually relatively new regulations that
the department will be dealing with we
haven't had uh funding that allows
Construction in the entire time that
I've been to the department I'm not sure
if ever I'm sorry Federal funding that
allows construction um so this is
something that we are in the process of
working through we are actively looking
to get more information from people who
are experts in using Federal funding
from um for construction but right now
we don't have um a great idea of who
projects I just follow up and ask there
will be a an application with
specifications from the local district
for the use of the allocated funds for
that
District
um can you sorry can you repeat
that I'm sorry
um there will be an application process
of sorts for use of the allocated funds
from M Two by The District yeah so um
with all of our funds school districts
are required to provide an application
to the Department of Education the
department of education's responsibility
is to review that application to make
sure that the activities are allowable
um so that will be no different from
this we can certainly um I can send Jen
for the list of allowable activities for
sr2 to distribute to the committee that
might be helpful for you all to have
you yes representative M thank you thank
you Mr chair um the committee sees these
two individuals Caitlyn Davis and Amy
Clark as terrific representatives of the
department thank you very much I I just
wanted to make a comment that much of
this information was presented to the
commission on school funding and it was
very clear from the commission that this
needs to be
addressed 594 does not deal with all of
the issues that are out there as school
funding but merely begins to address
parts of it so I would strongly
recommend the committee to support these
two bills because it it is sorely needed
chairman
okay are there further questions for
either Miss Davis or M Clark Mr chair oh
yes I'm sorry no
that thank you very much Mr chair um and
while we have um Miss Clark um uh with
us uh you know I had some there little
bit of little bit of um um you know
cross talker feedback when um when
representative Lyon was was asking a
couple questions about the the program
design particularly for moratorium
projects and then the uh the bond
questions and I and I think the the the
the bond Andor payment question should
have been directed to Ms Clark and I was
wondering if Miss Clark could um could
could take that up it had something to
do with the question about $20 million
time um do you have a quick answer to
that before we continue
that okay um so the I think just for
clarity I think the only clarification
um that I can make to what was said was
that the keep in mind that the state aid
is only on the principal Bond payment so
that's all I guess I would add I thought
that you did a good job explaining it um
it would be 20% uh you're you're correct
representative Le that it it's 20% of
that big number the 500 million so yes
about $100 million and I think House
Bill 594 identifies that the uh
Department of Education would make rules
or at least to me it is not clear that
house bill 594 States how that the term
of when that is paid um so I would
assume that the Department of Education
would have U make that Clarity in rules
but the only thing I would say is that
principal would be at the at I mean the
interest is covered by local taxpayers
currently and in The Proposal as
well thank
you sorry very very quickly I'm just
trying to understand this does that mean
that the 20% of those that ongoing
funding would just be um if you had A10
million loan you paid two million up we
had a two1 million paid construction
project 2 million was paid up front 8
million was spread split evenly over
those 20 years is it that simp simple of
math and then whatever cost of the bond
is is born by the towns or is it um so I
think there might be two two competing
things with house spill 594 the again
the way that I read it so there is a
retro for retro projects piece that's I
get I'm sorry I'm trying to talk about
the ongoing obligations I thank you I
could ask you questions all day but I
don't want to take everybody's time I'm
specifically
ask your is there a question that this
about right um I think our next um has
to fire um is up and I wanted to thank
Miss Clark and M Davis for uh their time
and testimony and next call on
Marat
um I assume everyone can hear me um this
is uh representative Greg Hill I uh
represent the town of Northfield and
one-third of the city of
Franklin um I'm here to
testify I guess against uh both these
bills um in in a manner of cander um I
should let you know that while I am the
chair of the school building authority
which was mentioned earlier by uh Amy
Clark I am not here speaking as the
chair of the school building authority
um this is more as a um as a
representative who's worked with this
for well since I've been appointed by
the governor and Council uh two years
ago or so um there were some a number of
things that were glossed over or not
mentioned at all that I would like uh
the committee to understand Dan
um I am not uh as I say I'm not here
speaking against it I think maybe U this
would be a good place for either a
retained bill um or uh something that uh
can be pushed off as um farther than
just making a decision in executive
session next week to uh to approve um I
think it's also important to point out
that um it is true as um honorable um
Dan Maguire told you last week that uh
the state has no money that it hasn't
first taken from the rest of us in terms
of taxpayers so this idea that the state
has money and uh the local districts
have um money is um not withstanding
whatever I am putting forward here that
this is actually the same pair of pants
with just different pockets of money um
I don't disagree with uh representative
luno um bill in one area and that is the
adjustment of percentages u based on
equalized valuation I think I think that
has Merit um and I certainly would
support that um in a in a further study
um I think it's fair to point out that
um in neither representative lad or
representative luno
presentation no mention was made of any
demographic studies or projections but U
but it's clear that the commissioner of
education has said repeatedly that um
we're looking at a somewhere 20%
reduction in in population over the next
uh I think he said decade or two decades
um that that affects this greatly um and
yet there was no mention about that I
think it's also important to point out
that um there are going to be changes to
how brick and mortar um buildings are
are done in the near future all you have
to do is look and see how many shopping
malls are being built um almost none and
and they're taken down um we are moving
further and further to more um virtual
spaces than we are brick and mortar
buildings and and it shouldn't be that
municipal buildings don't uh or or lag
40 and 50 years behind that Trend um it
seems that it needs to be addressed and
needs to be in at least in consideration
for any of these these longer year
projects um we also did not mention um
you know right now the current situation
uh with pandemic and we have uh
um how many of these schools aren't even
uh occupied at all um and I'm not
willing to guess next year what's
happening let alone what's going to
happen 20 years from now with these same
buildings um I think that's important to
put on the table um it's also important
to put on the table that um that school
buildings are a little different um for
one
thing there is state aid for school
buildings currently
um we have other municipal buildings um
fire and safety buildings for instance
in our
municipalities and and no one is um at
least maybe I'm letting the cat out of
the bag no one is uh is promoting that
there should be state aid for uh fire
and safety buildings and yet you know I
can't come up with a good reason why
that is um maybe there should be a uh a
municipal building authority um instead
of a School building authority um it is
um also a point here that was not
brought up there are two sections to
school building Aid um the only one that
was that was mentioned and highlighted
and is always highlighted is the grant
side of school building Aid um there is
an entire other section which is um
based on um using the uh government
um Bond credit
rating um so schools can apply to use
the the states Bond rating um and and in
some cases I'm not saying I have no idea
what the numbers are but uh but very few
schools ever apply and I don't know
during the
moratorium that that was not part of the
moratorium so school buildings did have
the ability to apply to use the State's
bond rating and thereby lower their
overall costs um I don't have the
information on that but it would be an
interesting um study it occurred to me
while uh we were talking about U
retroactively paying for projects that
were uh undertaken during the
moratorium um so it may be that we are
actually paying for well that's not
government money uh that's not State
money I should say it is merely used
using the the State's bond rating to to
make that
happen
um are really a little bit over the time
limit now we're we're sliding into our
next hearing we still have some folks
could you wrap it up quickly please yes
I can um I wanted to get into the meat
of of the individual um cases that we
have before us now as you can tell the
um there's more to be done with the
process of this than the money um it is
typical that um that we're trying to
throw money at a problem to solve it but
I'm telling you the process for this
school building Aid is ridiculously poor
um the timing as Amy Clark pointed out
you've got two to apply two years in
advance what's important for the board
to know or the committee to know is very
often the voters in that Community have
not yet um weigh in on whether to
approve or disapprove this
project prior to um all of this work by
Amy Clark and everyone else um actually
having to evaluate the project um it's
it's absolutely ridiculous it cries out
for a summer project for somebody here
um I would of the projects that we have
right now I'll give you two quick
numbers um so Amy spoke of the $104
million that if it's fully funded it
would be paid
for um by the state of that
57 somewhere between 57 and 71 million
of the 104 million um is going to be
built regardless of building
a I'll repeat that 104 million total is
the obligation that we're looking at now
57 to 7 1 million of those projects are
going to be built regardless of whether
building Aid is is approved or not um
there's also another um 12 million that
they're they're just setting aside the
project um some of that is in my own
community that they have no intention
this year of building um because some of
the numbers have changed their
demographics have changed they've got
two new studies they've changed so not
all of this is a carved in
stone um fixed look at the at the money
it moves it it's fungible um so in that
case I guess I'll wrap up the rest of it
there is much more to this story than
just adding more money to the project
and and with that um I will end my
testimony I'm happy to take questions
time
are there any questions for representa
Hill I have a question Mr chair yes go
ahead uh I guess I I am concerned about
uh representative Hill's
comments because if you listen to the
governor if you listen to the parents
there's a human outcry to return to
schools in buildings not
remote and secondly I'm not aware of any
state
requirement of this I'm gonna my
question is this I'm not I'm not aware
of any requirement from the state to
provide funds for
firehouses however I am con I am aware
of requirement for the state to help
fund schools am I incorrect in
that uh thank you for your question
representative Miler no that's exactly
what my point was um we we have we seem
to handle municipal buildings
differently thank you there is there is
no requirement for fire and safety um
and yet there is for schools yes but uh
that was my point and that's my point
mine as well as far as the other um
position on or your other question um it
it escapes me at this point I can't
remember what you were talking about
thank thank you very much are there
further questions for representative
Hill
W thank you Mr chairman uh very quick
representative Hill at you when you
started your dialogue you indicated that
you thought that the school building
construction similar to uh private
construction for uh malls and things uh
in the future would be less brick and
water and so I guess what is your
suggestion is your implication there
that you see in the next 10 years or 20
years that public education going to be
remote uh thank you for your question
representative um I don't think I don't
think I would be comfortable predicting
next week what's going to happen with
any of this stuff um who who would have
thought a year ago that we would be in
the position we are right now so um you
know the idea that we're we're
obligating the state and the state
taxpayers and the local taxpayers for
um what what this entire school project
looks like 20 years from now seems um
seems crazy is in light of the fact that
we're not taking into account our
current conditions that's all that was
my only point Thank you further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much representative Hill thank you have
home
to can you hear us represent K Hill oh
yes yes
sorry uh is it my opportunity to
testify thank you so much thank you so
much uh and I would like to share my
screen here if I may and I know that we
were all interested in and getting kids
back in person and unfortunately uh we
had an experience here in New Market
we've been able to have uh iners and
remote but we had uh a student and a
teacher a student uh exposed and tested
positively and so they've had a lot of
contact with the teacher and other
students so today we're remote only but
let me get to my
presentation
um right so uh as you know Mr chairman I
did sign in to hb214 because it's better
than nothing which is what we've done so
far and all the years that I've been in
the house and I know you've been working
on this before that um I strongly
support HB 594 because it addresses
project projects undertaken under the
moratorium which had stopped funding but
not time deterioration overcrowding or
obsolesence affecting many schools in
our state uh the state should serve as a
reliable partner with property taxpayers
and our communities as we invest in
schools to assure students their
families and businesses considering New
Hampshire that education is a priority
HP4 594 would also make adjustments to
Grant percentages as determined by the
economics of the district putting a bit
more where where there was less ability
to fund these projects failure to invest
in state funds leaves communities with
no good options projects are delayed
costs increase and students are
adversely affected over time conditions
become untenable and property taxpayers
are forced to fund the entire cost yet
another downshifting from the state to
local property taxes I begin with what
I'm most familiar with the struggles in
my own town New Market however we are
certainly not alone in this effort to
provide education yes sir I'm getting to
it I know I'm reading to it here's
here's what we had here's what we were
working with uh this you see this
collection of uh of additions so we
started in 1925 added something in the
50s then in the 60s and then we skipped
the 70s and wait till the 80s to add a
new gy that's this before picture uh
students 6 through
12 now we found two New Hampshire
companies wonderful companies bwell
Architects and ecan construction who
found a way to reconfigure the existing
and add 40% more space to that Junior
Senior High School we had that and the
space and the new modern air filtering
uh enabled us to offer in person uh to
me to more students than would have been
possible otherwise but you see we we
we've grown the building we found a way
to do it and here's the uh at the
elementary school we were we 30 years
ago we had we had to in add modular
classrooms because we had this bump in
uh enroll
which we need students we need kids and
you know 30 years later which is longer
than modulars are designed for we were
able to uh add real classrooms we were
able to um add a proper size gymnasium
and then use this space that had been
the cafeteria SL gym to which have a
proper kitchen and proper cafeteria we
no longer have five lunch classes uh
lent sessions so we've done that but
what did it cost it cost $9 million and
who paid for it New Market property
taxpayers and we're still paying for it
an extra 315 per thousand on our already
rate so uh what I'm getting to is that
um right now that we had the moratorium
we couldn't wait there's lots of other
places that couldn't wait uh page 15 of
the handout that uh Amy Clark provided
is that list and that list will grow if
we don't fund School building Aid get do
get started doing something and I would
like to see those on that list
retroactively helped just to the extent
possible so that we can be the better
state that we should be provide the
education that our students and our
families and yes our businesses uh are
entitled to thank thank you very much
representa kahill are there questions
kahill yes represent K have you uh sent
in uh as an attachment this testimony I
did send this this testimony to the um
to the committee I also sent uh two
letters from uh that Banwell and um and
emman wrote in
2017 which you know that was in support
of another bill which didn't get very
far so I'm hoping that uh this will lead
to a change so that we can we can
accomplish this yeah my question is so
uh we are in possession of of the what
the uh written comments that we're
seeing on the screen right now yes Mr
chairman thank you very much questions
for
repr um who put up the
uh can you please take down the uh the
screen share oh sorry yes um stop
share there we are thank you very much
yes we' like to invite this time Gary
Abbott
thank you very much uh chairman lad uh
for the record my name's Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire my testimony will be brief
because I've testified on this
legislation in the past I also have been
a lobbyist for many many years even
before the moratorium some 10 years ago
um the school building Aid has been very
helpful to many communities across the
state over the years Amy Clark has done
a great job of recapping that for the
committee I'm really here to just focus
on one thing and I think this is a a
concern of ours to
implementing School building Aid in the
future uh we really need to focus on
House Bill 214 and the 50 million do um
to put that into the statute we did have
a you know we had to do the moratorium
because of the tail and it exceeded the
$50 million as part of the budget
process we need a statute that sets in
place the $50 million so therefore the
Department of Education the legislature
can do the proper planning for the the
needs of the school
districts clearly Amy Clark has outlined
there's a lot of need I think uh that's
demonstrated by the uh survey it's also
demonstrated by the number of schools
that are currently applying without any
knowledge of whether there's going to be
the money or not and I think many more
schools would apply if there was a fixed
amount one of the concerns is is over
the last few years uh other issues have
clouded putting in place the $50 million
and I think this state has budgeted for
many many years the $50 million but it
was allocated to the
tail so what I'm trying to do here today
is I think that is the the key piece I
think years after that's locked in or
other legislation should then talk about
those other issues but my concern is is
if we don't get that in place uh we'll
be having struggles every budget cycle
so with that I'm just here to support
getting in place the $50 million I
support both bills because they both
have it in it but I think the issues get
clouded under 594 because you end up
with winners and losers you end up with
a whole host of uh different discussions
and almost should be a separate but you
need to get the money locked in for the
Department of
Education with that I would end my
testimony and answer anybody's questions
thanks Mr seen you in the hallways and
seen you on education prior to this so
welcome back are there any questions for
Abbott Mr chair actually a question for
you and I really shouldn't be asking um
Mr Abbott the question saying as you and
I presented um the bills but I just want
to point out that that there is a
difference in 214 and
594 with respect to
the you I should either be talking
there's a lot I'd like to add to
regarding Esser and some other comments
but uh I'll have to do that after this
hearing is over I think you should do
the same thing okay no happy to happy to
do that just wanted to clarify the
understanding thank you thank you very
much are there are there further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much Mr D have a great
day David
Smith representative
Smith David
Smith yes this is David Smith can you
hear me yes all right let me turn on my
video might be helpful to one
moment all right um so I prepared a
statement here uh in uh pulling it up
here so my name is David Smith I'm a
resident of New Hampshire um Hamstead
New Hampshire and a school board member
I want to say first thank you
representative Vlad uh and the steam
members of the committee for letting me
speak uh to you on the importance of
school B uh building
funding um I'm also a veteran of the US
Navy having served this great country
for five years um and I'm here to convey
594 as stated I'm a veteran and very
proud to have served this great nation
when I served in the US Navy I had the
great honor to travel overseas and visit
over two dozen countries I was able to V
visit the wealthy countries in Western e
Europe to the poor countries in Eastern
Europe and throughout Asia it was a
great experience because as a young
adult it made me very proud to be from a
country that is wealthy and Prides
itself in investing in the
infrastructure to provide the
prosper so 20 years later I have a few
more gray hairs I have few I have four
beautiful smart daughters and I've added
a few more
pounds I'm here in front of you with
many life experiences collected I've
been able to dabble in Industries
leading from the technology sector I've
worked for the largest defense company
in New Hampshire I've also worked for
the largest financial company in New
Hampshire and over the last two years
I've had the tremendous opportunity to
serve on the Hamad School Board
providing leadership to our community
and to the administration to serve the
students at our school district and do
whatever I can to support the 21st
century educational experience of those
students during those two years I've
experienced more than I ever anticipated
I've learned about all the amazing
techniques our teachers incorporate to
educate our children I have learned
about all the tire tireless hours our
teachers and administrators put in
before the school bell rings what they
do during the day in between their
classes to help a student with extra
learning needs or to answer the simplest
or strangest questions uh from our
parents and community and I've seen the
countless times when they partake in
events in the community with our
families they do this in the after hours
when they could be with their own
families excuse me Mr Smith um we uh
finding a little bit late with this
hearing um uh you could go directly to
your comments on the legislation yes I
promise so actually I'm getting right
into it right now so it's a good cue so
thank you um I've also had the esteemed
privilege to lead our school district's
construction committee project this year
and I would like to give you a brief
history of the past construction
committees in our town of Hamstead for
the past dozen years or so our school
board has attempted to get the approval
of Warrant articles by the community in
Hampstead these warrant articles were to
fix existing School problems in our
Central School that I feel should never
be problems as they cause an un
unhealthy learning environment for our
students this environment ultimately
proves dis disadvantageous to their
ability to compete with other school
districts in the state and throughout
the
country as I stated before I was
fortunate enough to travel overseas with
the Navy I was also during the this time
fortunate enough to take part in various
sponsored relief and volunteer efforts
which included visiting schools in
countries such as Romania to paint
hallways replace light and glass
pictures amongst other maintenance items
to you that to you and I seem pretty
routine however in those countries
having the resources to fix such small
items was anything but small now in
hamon Central
School I'm able to see firsthand issues
that remind me of those schools that I
visited while in the
Navy those countries that were in the
Iron Curtain behind the Iron Curtain in
Eastern Europe pleas address the bill
other I I thought I was representative
vad by providing I'm going into
providing what as an example a school
system is finding trouble to raise such
funds and is looking for from the state
I I'm about to provide just some
examples of a local school district that
um is struggling to provide a proper
environment for our students
representative Hill was allowed to talk
for 20
minutes I I just said go ahead please
representa okay thank you so here are
just a few of the building issues that
are facing Hamstead right now that we're
going to vote um that we're providing to
the taxpayer to vote on uh in March
these this is just a five these are five
items I could have easily given you
Dave's top 10 list but I'm going to go
I'm limit to five to um be respectful of
the time representative lad thank
you first one we have exterior walls
with an R value of 1.2 in one area of
the building that provides education
space for eight classrooms to give you
an understanding of what an R value of
1.2 is equivalent to if you built a toy
a tiny house made just of particle board
you would have greater insulation than
what these students have in this school
building this is not an
exaggeration in the winter we have to
turn up the heat of an Antiquated HVAC
system very high just to get the
temperature that is barely comfortable
it the noise from our HVAC is disruptive
and then in later spring months when our
kids return from summer break or are
about to go to summer break it is quite
unbearable and I'll give you the story
that one of those spring days I was able
to visit my daughter's classroom in this
area of the school it was in June to
celebrate the end of the year of the
classroom I was blessed to be able to
hear her and other students speak so
proudly of a year- end project when I
walked into the room it was unbearable
they have a thermometer hanging in the
middle of the room it was 92 degrees
this is not an exaggeration I have
pictures of this this is not okay for
our students number two we have intake
vents in the same part of that building
that is sucking in exhaust from the cars
that are dropping off our kids and
picking them up throughout the the day
these intakes are in the same part of
that building that I talked about with
the lack of insulation this section of
the building serves eight classrooms as
I said four for our kidney gardeners
four for our third graders this is
unhealthy and simply
unacceptable we ALS number three we have
small and inadequate rooms classrooms
that the square foot are under the
recommended Space by the doe in numerous
studies about having adequate spacing in
some cases these rooms are 30% under the
recommended size in only about 25% of
our classrooms throughout the Central
School are actually larger than the
recommended size by the doe the only
reason we're allowed to have these Spa
spaces is because we are quote unquote
grandfathered in again this is
unacceptable number four we have very
small spaces dedicated to the special
education population in our school and
it is growing as we had just heard from
um Amy Clark we pride ourselves in
providing the highest quality education
for these students we want to take take
care of them and keep them in District
we officially have only three small
spaces that our par Educators refer to
as the closets the total space allocated
to the special Leed does make doe
guidelines when you combine them
together but they just barely make that
the entryway to our school is small but
it's larger than those three closets and
I ask the representative sitting in the
large room right now to look around look
at the size of the room you're in right
now now divide that in five parts the
size of these three closets is the
equivalent to one of those parts that
you're sitting in just imagine being in
a professional trying to provide the
best care for our special education
students in a space that's called the
closet that is the equivalent of that
desk that you're sitting at right now
number five and lastly Hamad student
population is on the rise we currently
have a student population of 420
students that's serving prek through
grade four next next year we're adding
north of 500 or 80 kids to bring our
student population in this school to 500
in the forecast have us growing an
additional 60 to or more students over
the coming years in this number is
conservative we are growing and we don't
have the
space however what we've done to
accommodate and to be provide the space
that we need this year we've taken over
half of our library the library that our
students would traditionally go sit do
projects get extra help work with a
librarian to read to get away from the
classroom to really just get into those
books they no longer can do that we
don't have the space for them to sit in
the library they can go and find a book
and go back to their classroom maybe to
the hallway who knows where they'll go
but they will not be in our
library I'm afraid of what is next after
this year as we continue to grow because
we are utilizing 100% of our learning
space I cannot commit to anyone with the
future boards Administration in Hamstead
will have to do because we don't have
the adequate funding to provide the
adequate education however I feel that
without doing anything will'll be a
it'll continue to be inadequate and be a
detriment to Future
students which brings us to why I'm here
today again Hamad board has brought
forward articles to raise the money to
take care of the issues i' I've spoken
to and many other issues I've not spoken
to we're doing everything possible to
inform and educate our wonderful and
supportive community of the
needs we are out there every day on
social media knocking on doors making
phone calls having Zoom sessions with
our community to show the cost the value
and other efforts to reduce the impact
of the cost to the taxpayers will bear
even though past warrants articles
attempted to fix these issues they have
failed our community is already seeing
this in their taxes and they're afraid
that by raising the taxes they're not
going to be able to live in these towns
we don't want to force our community
members out because the taxes get that
high
thank you very ahead can I just finish
I'm sorry I am almost done I believe
that our town is not unlike any others
that have been spoken to to
date I believe that we have hardworking
community members that are physically
conservative and are very cautious to
improve investment of millions of
dollars that will impact their
taxes and for this reason I'm here to
ask and request that you consider
passing these
bills the states around New Hampshire
they support their towns with building
Aid you look North to us in Maine you
look south of us to Massachusetts in
other states throughout the country they
under the they understand the importance
of the aid they understand that to have
a 21st Century Learning environment that
adequate we are asking that you consider
this bill and pass it on pass it so that
students of New Hampshire can be
competitive with other students in New
England with the proper funding that
this bill provides our students will be
able to compete with students in our
neighboring states to receive the great
education that New Hampshire has been
known to provide and if we continue to
adequately support our students then
that will have a direct correlation to
educated Workforce businesses to
continue to be attracted to stay in New
Hampshire businesses that will start to
want to come to New
Hampshire businesses that will be
started in New Hampshire by investing in
the foundation of the education of
students New Hampshire will be able to
continue to be the Hub of educated
professionals and continue to rank in
the top percentile of important
measurements such as education
productivity and compet
compensation I am here pleading in
asking that you strongly consider
supporting hb214 and HB 594 to ensure
that there are grants available to the
school
districts I thank you very much for your
time very respectfully David Smith
Hamstead resident and School Board
member thank thank you very much Mr
Smith are there questions for Mr
Smith not seeing any hands Thank you
very very much for your informative
presentation thank
you who's up on
next uh General
conell
welcome um good morning uh ladies and
gentlemen thank you chairman lad and um
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak this morning my name is Jim
oconnell I'm a school board member at
large from the city of Manchester and um
I I'll be very brief this morning I I
here to uh speak in support of both of
these bills um I I think that they are
the minimum step necessary um I won't
regail you with the many stories I could
uh about the needs in Manchester but
just briefly I would tell you that we
have 22 schools some of those schools
are multi-building schools so 22 schools
represents a greater than just 22
buildings and some of our buildings date
from the 18 the late 19th century um we
have just concluded and we're still in
the process of finishing we've had a
draft report on our schools done by a
national organization called MGT and
that's available on the Manchester
School District website with quite a lot
of detail on our school buildings but uh
let me just say that our average school
building in Manchester is 70 years old
and we have uh kids in autism programs
in glorified closets with no windows and
no air conditioning we've converted
locker rooms uh without Windows into
classrooms and I could go on and on and
on I think probably everybody in this
room or most people in your room are
aware that there is a great need for a
building Aid in the state of New
Hampshire and I was very pleased Mr
chairman to hear you begin your remarks
by pointing out the direct effect on
educational outcomes for young people in
our state because of the buildings that
are that are
not capable of doing uh delivering a
proper education and of course as you
pointed out and what should be at at the
foremost of our minds is that this
inordinately affects the uh the least
amongst us it is the poorest communities
it is the children with the greatest of
needs that uh and minority children that
are affected the greatest by these
things so I encourage you I'm I'm I'm
pleased these bills are coming up I I I
um I think that the moratorium was uh we
could talk about the merits of whether
it was whether it was necessary or not
but it should be behind us now and for
the future um we need major investment
in infrastructure in the school
infrastructure in the state of New
Hampshire um I support both these bills
and I would encourage you to uh I would
encourage you to pass them I'd be happy
if there was any need to answer any
questions you might have with regard to
Manchester in particular and I thank you
for the opportunity to speak this
morning thank you very much are there
ell not seeing any thank you very much a
real informative presentation regarding
what's going on in Manchester thank
you uh we had one
deah yes I
can thank you very much for coming today
you're welcome to go
ahead good morning thank you chairman
lad for allowing me to speak on this
issue uh my name is Deborah Ford I'm the
business administrator for the masoma
Valley Regional School District um our
district comprises the town of Kanan
Dorchester Grafton Enfield and orange um
some towns that have very high tax rates
as you may know um I I'm WR I'm I wrote
my testimony and support of HB
594 um Mascoma School District over the
summer of June of 2015 through September
2016 did a a large renovation
21508 million renovation in addition to
our high school um it took us three
years to pass this through the voters if
it had passed during the first year it
was proposed we would be receiving
building aid but because um the
moratorium had gone into effect by the
time we got this bill um the warrant
article passed um we have not received
any building Aid so I just wanted the
the committee to understand that um our
building was built in 63 it was very
deficient um we did convince the voters
that it needed to be renovated and it's
a wonderful building now but it costs us
annually for these bonds $1.5 million
which amounts to over 5% of our total
$29 million annual
budget so I I'm just asking the
committee to um consider our situ
situation um as you debate the merits of
HB 594 and what it would mean to the
taxpayers of the masoma Valley Regional
School District thank you very much
thank you very much Deborah there
boy thank you very much it's always good
to hear somebody right out of the school
district giving us this B basic
information thank you thank
you um I don't have any other further
folks that are asking to testify on this
on either of these bills so at this time
I I'll close the hearing for the two
bills uh dealing with u going
Aid so with that uh this is Clos I don't
don't have the sheet in front of me as
far as how many people signed up for one
way or the
other
speak representative vad yeah um we have
Barrett
Christina Nate Green from the Department
of Education and Carl lad signed up to
speak um but I'm not sure if you have a
room uh okay uh on the attendees I don't
see any hands raised but are they signed
there the names I read are the only
people who um registered to
speak okay um well let's take who is the
first one you have there because I don't
have that information and I don't think
uh we don't have a representative to
bill
oh you're not talking about the bills
which we just did which are the uh 214
and
594 I'm sorry I thought you were moving
on to 242 I haven't opened up that
hearing yet oh I I apologize for the
confusion represent glad thank you very
much okay so we are now going to go into
H the presentation of 242 the content of
adequacy um I am the sponsor of that
bill so I will remove myself from the
chairs not literally but from the chair
and pass the gav on to repr ell thank
you Mr chairman I would like to open the
hearing on
h242 relative to the content of
education and call on Prime sponsor
chairman lad to introduce the bill okay
okay thank you very much uh repres lad
uh comes from hail New Hampshire and I'm
hb42 I'm going to point of order yes um
I I uh thank you Mr chair I was a little
confused by what Miss for was talking
about too but I think she was saying
that there were three more speakers
signed up to speak on the um the the the
previous bill
24 and 594 before you close the um the
hearing no I'm I'm very sorry I didn't
mean I didn't mean to cause any
confusion I thought representative Vlad
um was saying he didn't have the sheet
for the upcoming Bill and so I was just
letting him know what I had recorded for
the upcoming registrations so that was
my confusion I'm sorry all right so not
not people that were signed up to speak
on the previous gos okay thank you thank
you very much I'm sorry I'm sorry
chair signed up to speak on the prior
bills has had that
opportunity okay so now we are in uh 242
and I will go ahead and for those of you
who have a copy of the bill and part I'm
GNA walk through it and and explain as
we move down from page to page or Line
to Line uh this is a bill that deals
with the content of adequacy and it also
deals with the costing of adequacy so on
page one if you're looking at lines 10
where there's you'll see some changes um
and of course there's a change at the
top on line three where we see the
opportunity for an adequate education
but going down to line 10 there is a
what I call a significant change in
regard to criteria for an adequate
education adequate education shall
provide all students for the opportunity
to acquire and apply now we've learned
that through all our CP programming and
through what's going on in education
today it's just not the knowledge and
the skill you learn it's the ability to
apply that Knowledge and Skills and know
how to communicate your skills and and
and and make that knowledge uh work for
you or or for your your employer going
down to line 14 knowledge and skill we
added the word knowledge and to parallel
what we have elsewhere in definition we
use Knowledge and
Skills line
16 deals with knowledge of biological
physical and Earth Sciences to enable
them to understand and appreciate the
world and be around them as the way it
used to be but we added in and
engineering social economic and
geopolitical challenges uh this past
summer when I was working with uh Dr
Jeff who's the technical director of the
gold region science and engineering lab
in Hanover New Hampshire uh working with
the core of engineers uh this is a a
well guarded facility in Hanover with
wire and you can't get in place it's
huge size of the LV and the capital
building combined and they're dealing
with issues dealing with h climate and
dealing with the Sciences which deal
with those challenges that I speak to
that adding in there um in regard to our
world the the challenge of understanding
engineering I think that's fairly
obvious the social economic and the
geopolitical challenges around us are
huge right now if you were to look at
the Artic where I lived for 25 years
very close to the Artic and Northern
Alaska there are changes going on in our
world back in 1980 the ice cap had
approximately 7.8 8 million
kilometers now it has 3.6 million
kilometers that's has tremendous
geopolitical issues and challenges for
us in terms of that's becoming a prime
sea Lane growing through there it's
being claimed by many countries aside
from Canada and the United States we
might add in China and Russia so there's
keal challenges going on that our our
our young people coming out of school
should be prepared to uh address these
going down to line
26 skills for lifelong learning
including interpersonal techn
technological skills to enable them to
work
communicate we've had the directors at
the cor technical education uh uh
facility saying one of the most
important things we can have kids learn
is how to communicate communicate in an
effective manner so that word has been
added in under line 29 what is a sub
substantive educational content of an
adequate education I don't think I have
to remind the legislature and members
here attending today that it is the
legislator's responsibility to define
the delivery of an adequate education as
well as what is an adequate
education so this phraseology that's
been inserted now taking out reference
back in 20189 we have to do that just
more of a technical change an adequate
education is one which still students
with Essential Knowledge derived from
rigorous academic study applied learning
again the word apply therefore
opportunity for an adequate education
shall be shall be defined as rigorous
academic study and applied learning in
the following four knowledge domains
those domains are listed down below one
of things that has been done and working
down through on line seven you see it
used to be just pling science now we're
opening that up to biology physical
science and Earth
Science Under social studies it used to
be social studies we've heard from many
geography teachers throughout this state
that geography is kind of a missing
subject now in a lot of our social
studies classes so going back and
opening up Civics and government
economics geography and history if you
look at 306 rule 306 you'll find these
subjects are required to be taught in
our school
RS jumping down we've had a lot of
discussion line 15 before in the past
regarding the need for personal finances
to be taught to our young people
obviously how to balance a checkbook is
important so that is also inserted as
one of the core knowledge
domains what we changed is the area
where we used to have computer science
and digital literacy as a separate
domain teachers shall use academic and
applied instruction to teach the core
domains under paragraph one the
following skills shall be integrated
into the core domains the concept here
is that computer science and digital
literacy is a part of mathematics it's a
part of History it's a part of every
domain that we have we're using uh
computer technology today in
communicating uh I'm certainly not doing
mathematics now but I am practicing a
language art
skill looking at logic and rhetoric
logic and rhetoric are simply thinking
skills which we all believe that that's
one of the Prime things we have to try
to instill on kids is how to think and
how to use that ability to learn and
rhetoric is the ability to communicate
both speaking and written lines those
are skills that also belong immersed
into all the subjects above or those
domains going down to line 22 on page
two on receiving a valid completion
certificate from a state board approved
alternative program on high school Under
rsc4 call 23 shall Grant equivalent High
School Credit leading to graduation to a
student has completed such alternative
program and you'll see down in line 29
that we have program also included in on
what is an academic standard means what
a student should know be able to do in a
course which we have high school middle
school or at a level which we've had
because we in the elementary schools K
through 8 k28 is considered Elementary
as well as Middle School at the top end
we teach by grade level and subjects are
Tau thematically throughout the but we
have programs as well we have programs
for example clear technical education
those are programs and reading to
certification and but they are academic
standards that can lead towards
graduation you through the CTE centers
you can get concurrent and dual
enrollment as well and credit underneath
the cost of an adequate education on
line 31 or going down line
34 it the general court shall determine
the necessary specific resource elements
to be included in costing and adequate
education it is the
responsibility of the legislature to
Define an adequate education therefore
it's also to achieve that we must also
uh determine necessary specific resource
elements necessary to the uh to uh
equate to the costing of that
education within our Co costing formula
funding formula we have base cost and
that's line 36 the base cost represents
the essential peral resources apply to
general education students the
substantive educational content for the
opportunity for an adequate
education in addition to finding the
base cost funding the base cost the
general C finds and what we have is for
those students that have needs that
extend beyond these costs we have
differentiated Aid this is what we are
doing right now in current legislation
and I've been doing such as a result of
the recommendation that came out of the
joint legislative uh uh committee
looking at education funding and the
accountability for funding in
2008 which was a very B was a bipartisan
um Committee of which the the party I'm
in was part of the minority at that time
in 2018 this was also endorsed by a task
force that studied education funding by
a task force that had a chair which was
of this part that I'm a member of and
the opposite party was in the minority
but it seems that both of those groups
have agreed that we need to have a
differentiated Aid which matches line
six seven and eight the education needs
of special education students which
extend beyond the uh Bas in order to
achieve
adequacy for English language Learners
and for economically disadvantaged
students free of theuse I do not have
free uh excuse me the third grade
leading component in here um that we've
discuss that even on the funding
commission and it's an element which yes
it can be achieved and should be
achieved however um there are other
sources of revenue for that including
title one and it amounted to
approximately uh not a huge amount of
money so I I've taken that out that came
in um several years
back I'm not objecting to it be included
either but it it's not there in this
particular bill in this section base
cost means the per pupal resources
necessary to provide a student with the
opportunity to acquire an adequate
education as defined by the RSA in
situations where no additional
differentiated Aid is necessary to do it
to address the increased cost of
providing meta opportuni students who
have additional educational needs so the
the base cost is comprised of and you'll
see that in line 16 through 20 this
comes and been extrapolated right out of
recommendation all of us may have
concerns about how much is provided in
regard to each of these elements this
just identifies the elements the
legislature still has the responsibility
in working with the Department saying is
the pupil teacher ratio going to be 25
to1 K through2 is it going to be 330 to
one for grades three on upwards or is it
going to be changed that this bill
doesn't address that it just identifies
the the elements which are required to
be funded under base adus base cost and
statute PRI this has never had the ratio
for example 25 to1 30 to1 in statute
that is done by administrative rule done
by the Department of
Education on line 23 through 25 there
school shall demonstrated provise the
for an adequate education and that's
that's same mind which we've had before
and it it replicates those key domains
that are evidenced earlier in the bill
and lastly on page
four there is a section for
accountability that's been added in
beyond what we have currently in law the
commissioner shall provide the
legislative oversight committee
identified in RSA 193c col 2 we do have
a legislative oversight committee that
looks at this aspect of Education with
an annual status report by November one
the report shall include any school that
is unable to demonstrate that it
provides an opportunity for adequate
education through the input based School
accountability system we have two
systems we have performance outcomes and
we have this might support both
methodologies we need both outcome is
extremely important however I do not
believe outcome should be defined as a
certain cost number to meet the average
cost of a student based on our doe 25
forms that does not thoroughly Define
what those elements those key elements
those key domains are in education going
on in line 10 the department shall
Implement corrective and technical
assistance in accordance with RSA 193
e3e so there is a process where
technicals support can be off notice of
this status shall be posted on the
school and the school district website
the school or School District shall
provide written notice of such status to
parents or guardians of students
enrolled in the affected school so this
is the best way to be transparent and
open is to let parents know exactly what
we have in a school whether that the
inputs are being accomplished or not uh
it will be reflected on that
accountability system I believe that
this legislation clearly defines what we
have and what we asked for in terms of
defining adequate education and content
love and also clearly defines how we're
going to cost out an adequate
education thank you very
much uh thank you chairman wait a minute
I may have forgotten one other component
in
this beyond the differentiated a and
adequacy base that we call adequacy
there are two areas which fiscal
capacity disparity a is part of this and
those areas include the equalized
valuation prop property value per pupil
and secondly there is another one which
is coming forward in another bill 68
which defines that there's another area
of of disparity Aid provided for those
schools regardless of their will and
that's that's been always a concern to
myself that we have pockets of the
children with in schools that have high
equalized valuation per people over the
average of 1.14 million per student
that's the average equalized evaluation
these Pockets these schools have a
sizable number of level one and level
two students remember level three and
four are either your proficient or above
proficiency highly proficient on the
Statewide education performance uh
assessment so those schools would level
one and two qualifying students they
would receive funding also so the
funding formula is being proposed later
but within this area of finding the
adequate education an adequate education
is simply that of the Bas and the
differentiated a thank you very much
thank you I do see some members have
questions start with
representer uh thank you um Mr chairman
and thank you for
taking my question I'd like to draw
the to line to page three starting on
line
12 uh this uh deals with the definition
of the input uh to the costing of an
adequate education it's unfortunate that
the committee is uh reviewing this bill
at this time I requested of the chairman
lad to have a briefing of the committee
of the results of the Commission on
school funding it would have allowed the
committee to understand the commission's
report which was um unanimously with the
exception of Representative lad's uh
opposition to the commission's report
the commission's report would give you a
different approach to the funding of
schools this input approach to funding
of schools is basically a continuation
of the current way with which we fund
schools the commission is recommending a
different way of funding schools and
that will that is uh being presented by
Senator Khan in the Senate and I think
it's inappropriate for the committee to
hear only this particular approach
without having an opportunity to hear
what the commission spent the summer in
reviewing the data from schools for the
past 10 years and making a recommend
ation that's contrary to this particular
provision of this bill I again would
request that the that chairman lad allow
the committee to hear the report and the
recommendations and the findings of the
commission before we exact this
particular Bill thank you very much at
this point in time repr Miler uh I'm
responding to you even though there was
no question and it was not relative to
this bill HB 242 and as of this I will
be taking no more
interesting I got a question wow I got a
question really the prime sponsor is
said he was not taking questions the
prime sponsor of a bill that goes 180
degrees opposite from what the
commission to study school funding found
and you won't take a question that's
unbelievable something that a bill that
ments I mean Jim oconnell from
Manchester was just here talking about
how Manchester school buildings are
stuck a lot of them are stuck in the
1800s what you're proposing here is also
stuck in the
1800s
unbelievable additional two uh people
who would like to testify on this bill
um and I'll try and bring up uh Mr
Christina
that's
pretty I'm I'm here
folks uh thank you to the committee um
uh uh chairman cordelli thank you for
recognizing me uh for the record uh
Barrett Christina executive director of
the New Hampshire school boards
Association um we um we are opposed to
House Bill
242 um we think that there's some uh
some Merit to some of the language in
the bill um it certainly um in some
aspects um does reflect what we think is
is a good update to to to the adequacy
statute um I'm going to point to a
couple concerns that nhba um has with
the bill though uh I'm on page two um
starting on line 22 it's sub paragraph B
it begins upon receiving a valid
completion from a state board approved
Alternative Program uh the the high
school uh shall Grant equivalent High
School Credit leading to graduation this
is the learn learn everywhere language
that we saw a couple years ago um that
they're just moving that around and and
making it clear to um uh to follow the
Department of Education regulations
about learn everywhere that if a kid
goes off and takes a an alternative
program um that and from an approved
learn everywhere program the high school
has to give them credit um alternative
program should be defined there are
multiple places in Statute in which an
alternative program is referenced there
are Provisions in the Department of
Education rule 306 there are alternative
programs under RSA 193 colen one which
is the mandatory attendance statute and
Governor Lynch put that in back in like
2008 basically for atrisk kids who are
at risk for dropping out you school has
to develop an alternative plan for them
to hopefully graduate from high school
so by just saying alternative plan we've
got three or four different places in
law where there's references an
alternative plan doesn't indicate which
one um the other problem with putting
that language about these alternative
programs if it does relate to sort of a
learn everywhere program under the doe
the 1400 rules um you're you're putting
in the adequate education statute
there's a simple argument for a parent
to make that the state then has to pay
for that Alternative Program um and the
state has to pay for adequacy we know
that um so if if this alternative
program is not being offered by the
local school district and it's from some
outside vendor um uh Girl Scouts uh
Signum University I believe was just um
approved as a learn everywhere program
my argument is that the state's going to
have to pay for it then because it's
part of an adequate education um that's
one that's one challenge that we have
with the um with the bill uh moving on
to page three I'm on line 12 the subar
paragraph about um 1A where it talks
about base cost um and we have listed
out teacher specialty teachers um and
glad to see facilities operations and
transportation included in there because
those really are not currently funded as
part of the the adequacy formula um but
we think that there should be other
things included um within there I I see
online 16 it does relate to it speaks to
Specialty teachers I don't know if
that's intended to cover special educ
ucation um but to the extent that
special education is going to be
included in this I think that should be
should be
clarified um also to the and and I
understand that the rules and the
statutes don't always match up and they
should um but we've heard a lot of of
testimony um and a lot of bills the last
couple years about Workforce Development
um Alternative Learning programs
Extended Learning opportunities um it
would make sense that extended learning
opportunity coordinators would be
covered for our high schools as part of
an adequate education if that's what we
want to move to I don't I don't see that
in here um so if if that's a prerogative
um uh of of of this committee and
certainly Statewide we should include um
Extended Learning opportunity
coordinators as part of the the the the
adequate
education um I'm on page four now uh
line the the last paragraph subar
paragraph and sort of that new bold
language um I I I I get that there needs
to be oversight from from the Department
of Education there needs to be oversight
of the legislatures and the status of
our schools but I I read this about um
um uh corrective action technical
assistance noticing it on the on the
district's website um when I first read
this I I my first thought was that we
had reverted back to No Child Left
Behind back in 2001 and 2002 um when we
had to provide all these notices of a
school was not making it or you know
based on whatever criteria um had been
established at the by the federal
government at that time it just we we've
sort of moved away from that
um so I mean I I don't know why that's
necessar necessary um and the last
objection nhba has to the bill um and I
I I may be off on this I I don't always
understand sort of the legislative
processes and what bills get a fiscal
note and what bills don't but if we're
talking about you know what an adequate
education the base cost of an adequate
education and we're making significant
changes to to not just the curricular
aspects of what a school dist has to
cover but um again that that language on
page three line 12 about base cost means
and then it list of teachers and
Specialists guidance counselers it seems
that there should be a fiscal note
attached to this too um as to what what
though what all those things are going
the cost and I know that we've got
issues with the the study commission and
bills relative to that and bills
relative to funding but um I think there
should be a fiscal note included with
with the bill as well too or at least
some analysis as to what all those
changes are are going to ultimately cost
so um that's NH hba's testimony I'm
happy to take any
you none thank you very much thank you
thank you chairman
we'll move on
last uh good morning uh thank you very
much uh chairman cordelli um and members
of House Ed um my name is Carl lad I'm
uh the executive director of the New
Hampshire school administrators
Association uh nhsaa has not taken a
formal position on this bill we are
neutral um we do have a number of
questions um one of the reasons why
we're neutral on this bill is because we
recognize uh representative lad's
passion about um uh the content of an
adequate education uh he has been um
he's been a a strong voice in this area
for um for many years uh and we
understand the intent of what he's
trying to do we do have some uh
significant questions uh and concerns
about the bill uh some of which um uh Mr
Christina brought up so I will not um
I'll not reiterate those ough we do
share the same concerns uh I do have um
a few questions about uh some of the
language of the bill um and what the
implications are uh at the top of page
two on line one uh where it says
knowledge derived from rigorous academic
study and applied
[Music]
learning un unless we're going to use
the definition of I know it when I see
it um we need to have a a clear
definition of what is going to
constitute rigorous academic study
because that may mean very different
things uh for Handover High School uh as
opposed to another school in the
state I'm also a little concerned about
the definition of logic and
rhetoric um I I think that that needs to
be much more clearly defined uh because
if we're talking about critical thinking
skills uh those are already in uh the
minimum
standards
um on line 22 Begins the section about
the valid uh completion certificate uh
if these alternative programs are going
to be uh awarded the same type of credit
as the core academic standards up above
um do these alternative programs uh do
they have to meet the core requirements
uh that are listed above um or is it
just uh any state board approved program
and then as I was reading through this I
was really um confused about why we're
not talking about
competencies um because the the state
has identified competencies competencies
are in the minimum standards uh for
school approval uh all of the
instruction and assessment uh that go on
in public schools now are based on
competencies uh so I think that there's
there's some confusion around here um
and that
clarification again um on line 36 when
we start talking about the cost of
inadequate education it says the base
cost represents the essential per pupil
resources again I would just ask for uh
some
clarification on line uh excuse me on
page three uh when uh on beginning on
line nine when we're talking about the
cost of fiscal capacity disparity Aid um
provided to
municipalities um with the lowest
equalized property valuations per pupil
uh I'm unsure whether that means the
lowest quartile the lowest third the
lowest half of the state um so I think
that would probably need to be further
defined um and then I do believe that uh
the next section is a step forward uh in
that um we have never had uh all of
these categories included uh in the cost
of an adequate education including uh
facilities operation maintenance and
transportation and I did for for some
reason I did sign up to speak to the to
the last Bills on building aid but
understand with everything going on that
that that probably some balls got
juggled and dropped which is fine could
be on my end um um but I do think that
the facil operation and maintenance is
incredibly important in the cost of a
base adequate
education and then uh uh finally I'd
like to um just talk a little bit about
um starting online 10 uh where it says
the department shall Implement
corrective and technical
assistance um I I just question the
Department's capacity to provide any
kind of technical assistance uh they're
unable to provide the assistance that's
currently required by Statute regarding
School approval um visitations and this
was prior to co um and to provide
technical assistance on curricular areas
and scho and schools who are uh
determined to be uh in need of
improvement so as we look at this bill
and we look at a number of other bills
uh that says the department will provide
oversight I think we have to really
think about the totality of what we're
asking the department to do um because
they simply do not have the capacity uh
to to provide the kind of oversight that
is imagined in this bill and then
finally on line 14 it says the effective
date shall take effect 60 days after the
passage now if this bill were to be
enacted uh in this legislative session
and it were to uh be signed into law uh
that would most likely not happen until
June all of the high school schedules
are long since written students are
assigned to classes in May budgets have
been approved in March uh so there would
be no opportunity to be able to meet the
requirements of this legislation if it
was uh to be enacted that
quickly as a recommendation um and
certainly if the State Board of
Education is going to go into rul making
around this uh it would it needs to be a
much longer effective date something
like two years from now uh in order to
be able to make this effective and um uh
and purposeful for school districts
again um you know we're always happy to
to support and help where we can um we
are not taking a position on this bill
but it does raise serious questions um
with all due respect to representative
Vlad I don't think it's ready for prime
time just
yet and with that I'll end my testimony
thank you thank you and I'm sorry if we
missed you on the last bill but you were
not on
our list so um apologize
oversight um we do have some
questions
represent yes I thank you for taking my
question I was Wonder through you
mention is
um on the last page of the
bill line 10 the department Implement
cor and technical assistance in
accordance with RS
193 and then you mentioned that the
department is not following through not
able to keep up with the current
technical assistance demands I was
wondering if you could give me an
example of uh What uh what we might be
able to look at as far as that goes
thank you um representative Hobson thank
you for the question um one of the one
of the areas of technical assistance
that um districts have not had for many
years now uh has been in the curricular
areas uh there used to be a Content area
specialist for language arts
mathematics um uh Humanities uh and
science uh those positions no longer
exist um and as more uh competency uh
driven work uh has been asked of school
districts there's been little to no
technical assistance available from the
Department that's not through they're
not wanting to provide the resources
they just have been unable to um several
years ago the department went through
a um a kind of a reorganization if you
will um and I and certainly understand
the need to
reorganize uh bureaucracies uh when
necessary uh but there was a school
approval process where um
representatives of the department would
go out into the field and actually visit
the schools um and look at both their
curricular and building needs uh as they
were going around to ensure that
students were um or that school
districts were providing the correct
inputs now it is really just based on a
survey uh that is sent out uh because
there's only one person in the
department uh who does yman work uh but
it's impossible for her uh to get out
into the field uh to visit every public
school that's up for school approval uh
within their cycle it's just it's not
possible uh not physically possible not
because she doesn't want to it's because
she can't be there we'd have to hire her
a helicopter uh in order to do that so I
just think that as we look at this and
as we look at Innovation schools and as
we look at scholarship programs and we
look at all these things that we're
anticipating the department to provide
oversight and technical assistance on I
just want us to be cautious that it's
really not realistic and it's not
because they don't want to they just
don't have the resources so unless
you're willing to pour a lot of
resources into the department I I just
worry about the ability of the these
things to be met in the manner in which
you wish that they would be I hope that
answers your question it does thank you
very much thank you any further
committee me me
yes M thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you uh Mr lad for taking my question um
so with regards to looking at this uh
this sort of formula for funding here um
do do you feel that it addresses the uh
differences between let's say someplace
like Manchester which uh we know
is experiencing
tremendous upheaval in trying to meet
the demands and the needs of their
diverse student body um and and some of
the Suburban towns I mean what what what
does this do for the inequities between
the Suburban towns and and the
city uh that's a great question
representative Mullen and uh again with
no fiscal note attached to this it's
very difficult to actually see what the
implications of the bill are um I do
think that um there because of the way
that um there is some fiscal disparity
Aid written into the bill um that that
may that may be um a supplemental
support um but again without seeing a
fiscal note it's hard to
determine so just a followup M Mr chair
so so what you're saying to me then Mr
lad is that looking at this you wouldn't
be able to make predictions on uh how
much academic Improvement Manchester was
going to be able to achieve with what's
written in the Bill thank you for your
question question yet um because it's an
input based system that would be very
difficult to determine and again
especially without a fiscal note to
determine what kind of resources are
going to be targeted to those most at
risk students thank
you than you any further questions from
the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much uh Mr L your testimony thank you Mr
chairman um is there a uh Mr Green who
wanted to
testify been alerted that you might want
list
green hi good morning um I had signed up
this morning so that I could be
available as a representative from the
Department of Education but I don't have
any specific testimony to provide on the
bill okay thank you anyone have any
questions for our department
representative see none I do there
ises thank you I'm sorry to monopolize
this but I'm fascinated um Mr Green
uh we have been uh we've been looking at
the components of an adquate education
in this bill obviously by name and I'm
wondering if the department of UC tion
has given any feedback as to where
social emotional learning fits into the
education uh we have not because it's
not specifically called out here uh in
RSA thank
you
any
questions uh seeing none thank you Mr
Green for uh offering your assistance
oh sorry resident blus One More Mr
Green I was just wondering what the
comments made earlier about um the
Department of Education being
overwhelmed as it is do
you what are your thoughts on that as to
actually so we do hope to create a more
robust School approval system that's
based upon the minimum standards and the
school approval standards that are
currently outlined uh in the RSA and in
the 8306 the administrative rules here
with the Department um we do have a
position for a school approval person um
that we've recently hired for that
individual will be starting at the
department on July 1 so I'm hopeful that
bringing on that full-time position
starting in July will help to alleviate
some of the burden that the department
has thank you very much
thank you thank
you once only twice I don't see anyone
further thank you Mr and thank you Mr
chairman with that I'll conclude the
testimony on HP
242 and I guess we can break for lunch
at this point and come back 1:00 for
yes
know
somewhere
else okay good afternoon to everybody
that's out there on in remote and those
is we're ready to go ahead with this
afternoon uh hearings we have two
scheduled the first of which is HD
320 and uh with that I'd like to
recognize representative M Prime sponsor
uh thank you chairman uh for the record
uh I am representative Mike morett Marat
District 9 which includes uh and L
NASCAR country um we spent a lot of time
today talking talking about money and uh
this afternoon I'd like to redir a
little bit and talk about
learning uh Mark Twain
said that everyone talks about the
weather but nobody does anything about
it so similarly it seems like everybody
has talked about the wful state of
civics knowledge amongst uh so many
Americans or most Americans uh but
nobody does much about it so HB 320 here
provides us I think with a wonderful
opportunity to actually do something
about it improved learning and and and
knowledge uh what this major does it
would simply require a universal Civics
assessment is a graduation requirement
we already have a requirement to have
these classes but this would add a an
assessment to the classes simply
utilizing the 100 question history and
Civics examination this currently being
administered to prospective natural R
citizens uh this proposal came up a
little bit short the last time around
three years ago but we're hopeful that
we can uh move it forward this year now
it's not a a radical notion or radical
bill at all this exam is already a
graduation requirement in in h a good
number of states uh Arizona raho North
Dakota South Dakota uh South Carolina
Tennessee Utah Louisiana among others
so this is already being done so why do
I and so many others want to see New
Hampshire join these other states in in
uh requiring this exam this this
instrument this
assessment it's because we want to do
something about the the rful state of
civics
knowledge we think it's crucial that we
have citizens who who understand a
little bit hopefully a lot but at least
a little bit about government
uh and there are countless examples one
can find on the internet and I won't
share them here I can I can sense them
out later if you like of uh surveys
YouTubes and and in statistics that show
people so many people don't know
anything or how anything about how
government works and to some of us
that's very disturbing and it's even
even scary some people are less worried
about this uh this lack of knowledge of
the signant and and uh I'm not amongst
them uh and I think this lack of
knowledge reflects B on their
educational experience uh especially
resonates with me because uh I a former
Civics teacher and as someone who's
taught for three different colleges in
New Hampshire uh I've been consistently
disappointed I've been out in those
trenches so to speak I've been
disappointed if not appalled at the
utter lack of civics knowledge displayed
by college students I I could give
examples and and and I I won't at this
time uh now every school district
handles Civics education differently
some do better than others but what this
assessment would do would would be to
establish a common Baseline of
fundamentals for all schools now what
concerns many of us is so many schools
do not give students the basic Civics
instruction they feel they deserve that
they parents expect and the society
needs and some schools conflate uh
contemporary issues classes with Civ
classes and they're not the same it
shouldn't be the
same um the result is that many
so-called Civics classes end up focusing
on talking about contemporary issues
climate change or whatever which is fine
but we think that before you start to
talk about some of these contemporary
issues you should understand the
structure of of our of our government so
I I want to briefly respond to some Curr
concerns I've heard about this me uh
number one we should not dictate
curriculum actually obviously we do that
came up this morning in terms of uh
curriculum that we dictate uh and we
should have statutes to give schools
some Direction that's our job so I were
elected to the house and to the
legislature to the education Committee
in particular uh we already have Civic
requirements in the books I co-sponsored
one of them Senator Dallas Ando earlier
now this Bo would provide some
now Senator Dallas Sanders B I support
and signed on but it it didn't have any
specific uh requirements other than you
need to have the class so this I think
enhances Senator Dallas Sandro's earlier
intent um and as mentioned earlier many
states already do this I don't think we
should mandate for example every St to
take a French class or a trigonometry
class but I do think it's our
responsibility to expect the high school
graduate of some basic Bic language
English skills and a basic knowledge of
civics uh number two uh the second
concern iocc that this is a stressful
and unnecessary quote unquote high
stakes
requirement uh it's arguably high stakes
I suppose in that we want it to be a
graduation requirement but the testable
material is out there it's very easy to
study for students have the questions
and the answers ahead of time many
fourth graders and eighth graders if
this moves through uh fourth graders and
eighth graders uh can take and satisfy
this requirement even before high school
and I think this would be a source of
Pride for them and their families and
their schools uh it's one of my High
School principles used to also say
students deserve a chance to fail I
think shielding students from from
failure or from challenges does them no
favors and this allows of course local
flexibility in administering to special
needs
students and number three concern uh
that this measure will encourage again
quote unquote teaching to the test uh
those are education I know that the the
notion of teaching to the test is kind
of a pejorative expression uh it's often
used by those who are frankly threatened
by assessments and they're threatened by
accountability uh teaching to the test
is not a bad thing I it's
driver ed instructors teach to the test
it's called the driver's
exam law professors teach to the test
it's called The Pri
exam uh I at the nhti uh the
radiography uh professors there teach to
the test it's called the national
registry exam for x-ray text and I want
somebody take my Ed who have studied for
that test so this this teaching to the
test thing is something that I just
don't don't uh I don't buy so anyway
mapping this up I say if this is the
type of measure that parents want that
many of us want that our country needs I
think and someone who believes in and
supports public education this is very
important because I I'm a product of
publication public education I've taught
in public schools kids went to Public
Schools we need public schools and we
need to support public schools and we
need people to support public schools
and I know that we've all been seeing
examples and concerns with people who
have lost some confidence in public
schools so if you support Public Schools
here's a great opportunity to do
something that will help increase
confidence and support for public
schools with this little measure that
provides assessment and a little bit of
accountability uh I mentioned Senator
Dallas c i co-p to similar measures in
the past when I brought this up last
time on Sunday Mark full Clark uh from
the other party as a co-sponsor so this
is a bill that has sponsorship and
support from both parties it's a nice
opportunity for bipartisanship that I
hope will not be lost and finally uh in
closing I want to come back to the late
Mary guile who we all know uh she once
chaired this committee uh Mary was a
friend and a colleague of mine for many
years going back when we were both at
nhti in fact she also used the photo
that I took for for her first campaign
brochure back in
1996 anyway when uh this B first came
left three years ago Mary representative
God was very excited about it that
version of this committee after I gave
similar
testimony uh she spoke up and waxed
eloquent about what a great idea she
thought it was and and some of you know
Mary is a
Canadian uh represent of God came to
America became the naturalized citizen
and in so doing she had to satisfy some
some similar testing requirements to
become a citizen so you're on on about
uh how much she thought this was a great
idea but uh when it came to exec session
she voted against it and I understand
why uh our party's caucus uh before exec
sessions caucus just came up with
represent Val talking about this during
the break uh he knew where a caucus once
in high school because he had a civics
class in high school school so parties
we we both caucus before exec session
and we pretty much come to exec session
knowing how we're going to vote and
that's our system um and I think
caucuses might be an interesting topic
for civics classes and for students to
understand better but after the students
have taken our naturalization and the
assessment test and know maybe a little
bit about government so right thanks for
your patience and forbearance and I I'd
be happy to take any questions thank
very much uh representative M are there
any questions for representa yes uh
represent oh excuse
me my class is on
here did you recognize me Mr chairman
yes I did okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman and and thank you
representative for uh taking uh the
question um I certainly share with you
uh your concern about the lack of uh
Civics knowledge or even historical
knowledge I teach history and uh I can
vouch for what you're saying um but I do
have some concerns here
um you noted that um the answers are all
out there and I've looked it up I mean
you can find them anywhere on the web um
to theuh 2020
exam uh so my question is uh at least
initial question is what is it that
students will learn I mean all they need
to do is just look at it online memorize
the answers and that's it they can take
the test and they will probably pass it
I had a test like that in college where
the Prof gave us all the answers in
advance I don't remember a single damn
thing from it uh because he gave us
everything in advance and that seems to
be what would happen here so how would
you um characterize this as rigorous
academic study if all the answers are
out there and available in advance sure
representative I thank you for your
question I said it was rigorous academic
study I think it really is is is pretty
easy uh it it it's pretty much Basics uh
to your point um I think that students
uh need that broad Baseline now I know
and I've taught as you know in several
colleges as well and one of my concerns
is that uh oftentimes in in college
classes uh student students or or
professors will talk about certain
things that require a knowledge for
example to go back to the the climate
change thing I mentioned before uh if
some contemporary issue class or class
is talking about climate change and
people say we need a law yeah we need to
do this uh well I think that if if some
of these classes encourage some activism
which is good if the students talking
about climate change don't know how to
take action in terms of uh influencing
their legislature if they don't
understand about uh how a blow becomes a
law I mean look what we're doing here uh
I I think that these are just Basics
that we need to build on to to do what
you're talking about I think which is to
have higher level uh you know uh
pedagogical uh
experiences Mr chairman just a brief
followup yes you may thank you Mr
chairman and thank you again for taking
the question um the Naturalization exam
as it's currently administered my
understanding is that for in order for
one to pass it um and be eligible for
citizenship you need that you'll only be
asked 20 out of the 128 questions and
you need to answer only 12 of those
those 20 correctly I.E a grade of 60 so
um is there any particular reason why uh
you want to have the students take all
128 questions and attain a grade of 70
which in my structure would be a c minus
thank you sure that's thank you that's a
good question and you're correct uh the
the 100 questions are out there of which
the prospective citizens uh as you said
do take 20 they need pass up that's the
standard for uh you know immigrants some
whom obviously didn't go to school here
and maybe have some language
requirements I think to have a a
somewhat higher bar for New
Hampshire high school graduates uh is
important and uh and it's not a very
high B in the the perspective
naturalization students uh presumably
would have to study all 100 questions uh
of course they don't know which uh which
12 they would get it's like a driver's
test you study whole driver's manual and
hopefully know the whole driver's manual
and then you get uh 20 Questions out of
that so uh yeah I think it's a very
little bar 100 questions 100 pieces of
knowledge of civics government in
history uh that uh I think uh would be
good for everybody to the study some
schools do but my concern is are the mle
schools that really don't do as well as
they should here in my view thank
you thank you very much uh are there any
further
questions from the L uh thank you Mr
chairman there's no there's no question
that that civic's knowledge is very
important in fact I I was thinking as
you were making your testimony represent
Moffet that perhaps uh a requirement
must be for representatives in this uh
August house should pass that exam
before they become uh officially
recognized as a representative but as
that's another issue the question I have
for you is that it it appears to me that
this is now a high state test for
students and I just need need a
clarification because once a student has
passed all their other course
requirements etc etc that they have this
one exam that they have to take in order
to to get graduation is that correct is
this you consider this a high stake test
because you have to pass it in order to
get your graduation
certificate yeah thank you Mil uh I
actually spoke directly to that earlier
I specifically mentioned that this would
be perceived as a high stakes test and
it it is uh obviously if this is a
graduation requirement uh yes it is a
high stakes test in that sense I don't
think it's a hard test I think it's a
very very easy test as I said uh I think
fourth graders and eighth graders uh
probably cannot if if this moves forward
uh junior high students can knock off
this requirement uh in some cases would
a would a senior still need in some
school to take it over whatever that
probably will happen uh and that's okay
um and as far as legislators taking this
exam uh I had a very similar thought
that you had and I I did not give
expression to it but I'm glad that you
did well just as a as a followup so if
if in fact a student were to take this
exam let's say in the e8th
grade and pass the exam
then would they have to take it
again after the 12th year of of
studying h no not is uh our intent is
that at some point uh someone take and
pass this exam and get that Baseline of
knowledge we know fourth graders and
e8th graders uh you know we see a lot of
fourth graders we used to here at the
state house because that's a fourth
grade class class uh I think fourth
graders could take this and pass it and
knock it off and the school district
would have a record of it and I think it
would be a wonderful source of Pride I
think that would create a great deal of
excitement for fourth graders or eighth
graders to compare schools and study for
this and and uh honestly I think this
requirement in many districts could
probably be knocked off in uh in junior
high school but but this isn't part of
your bill at this point in time correct
uh correct it's the bill is very short
simple and hopefully sweet uh it just
asks that the school districts uh have
this uh assessment as a graduation
requirement at some point yes thank you
are there further questions represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative for bringing this
forward uh again um I think it would be
interesting to have uh Representatives
take uh the assistantship test but but I
think even more appropriate might be a
test on the
Constitution um uh the
other thing I wanted to ask about was um
if the student does not reach the grade
of
70 um on this test um it would be U
allowed there would be nothing to
prevent them from taking it again or
possibly a third time if necessary is
that correct sure it's a uh I I think
that the assumption is that students can
have as many shots at it as they need I
think like I said it's not a hard test
most people will do it easily some
special needs kids who have special
accommodations and that would be up to
the districts to uh to to make happen um
but sure if somebody needs to take it a
number of times uh John F Kennedy Jr if
you remember flun the buyers in then he
flunked it again and reason we know that
is because he was you know the hunk
flunk we get a lot of attention but um
yeah it's like a
bar much easier sure I I students could
take it as many times as they as they
needed so that takes a lot of the
pressure off of this this high stakes
concern in my
view yes you have follow thank you um So
based on what you just said I think
rather than teaching to the test
wouldn't it be more like learning to the
test I like that yeah uh learning to the
test is yeah in fact this is a test it
really doesn't need to be taught it
needs to be studied the material is
there study it learn it and hopefully
part of this process is uh this basic
knowledge Foundation is grown it'll
excite some students to ask questions
beyond the some of the basics of uh
tripod tyte government or whatever and
get them excited about uh government and
history and uh and become better
citizens
ultimately thank you very much uh
representative
Corell thank you and thank you for
taking my question so if you're a senior
you've passed all your classes um it
worked really hard because you're not
that great of a student but you've
worked really really hard um it comes to
the end you've been accepted into a
college and then you don't pass this
test so you don't get your high school
diploma you probably can't go on to
college so what do you do for the next
year when you've passed all your classes
but you haven't passed this test do you
go back to high school and just keep
taking this test or what do you do for
for that
year yes thank you we cor uh yeah we we
anticipated that type of question I
tried to address it in my earlier
remarks and my earlier statements uh
that scenario uh theoretically Could
Happen uh but some it depends on every s
i again I Envision this being taken care
of uh in eighth grade or ninth grade but
if for some reason some senior uh and
this is on them if they if they didn't
study for it didn't take it if the
school would make sure that they took it
uh what you described could happen and
if that did happen I think that that
might be a wonderful lesson for that
student to uh to do a little bit better
planning but I I don't think that would
ever happen I think that guidance
counselors and teachers and the school
you know if this is a ninth grade
requirement or an eighth grade
requirement uh I don't think the the
notion of the scenario of the scor as
you described uh that I don't think that
would be a showstopper um but thank you
for for the question it is something we
thought about sure followup yes
you um it doesn't anywhere mention
Public Charter School in this it just
says schools so would this also be a
requirement for a a charter school for
graduation Because unless something
specifically says Public Charter School
it doesn't apply to
them thank you for the question um I
look at the wording again the intendance
for public schools as you know charter
schools are public schools uh and well
it's a very short bet we look at the
word again and make sure that it's uh
it's clear if we need to find T and will
to before exec session we we certainly
will but yes uh the expectation is that
uh you know any appr approved school
that uh in New Hampshire be it chartered
public or public uh this is a
requirement that we would like to have
uh on all all all schools
yes thank you thank you very
much thank you m chairman a lot of
schools high schools
accept stud that taking the eth grade
but this be one of those things that
could have been done in eth grade in the
high school would then accept that great
yes good question represent B every
district is different uh I know when I
was in in uh eighth grade I was able to
take a French class in in my district it
it a lot because there was an upper Lev
French class I get high school credit
for it so to answer your question it's
up to the districts but absolutely I
would think that as I've said earlier
that uh it's not a class it's a test and
so if you pass a test if you pass a
driver's test when you're 16 it's uh you
know even better than passion when
you're 18 so yes to your
question
repres thank you Mr chairman uh and
thank you representative for taking my
question um I actually have two with
them but if I read the the New Hampshire
requirements correctly we already have a
half credit requirement in Civics
education already is that
correct yes I I believe that so yes that
Senator Dallas sand actually as I
mentioned ear here and I uh uh got a doe
to that to that effect into statute yes
okay so my followup question my m is the
chair that regards that what uh my
concern is two parts a what would you
what would you take out of the current
Civic curriculum that they're trying to
get in there in half a year uh to put
this test to training of this test in
there uh that's the the first part and
secondly uh what happens to the concept
of local control of content and
curriculum thank you for for the
question uh nothing would need to be
changed in terms of curriculum this is
just a a test that could be given could
be given via Blackboard it could be
given Junior High School uh it's no need
to for any school district to adjust its
curriculum whatsoever uh they just would
need to in some fashion that's up to the
local control up to the district to uh
administer this assessment at some point
in during the student's Journey uh so we
have no impact on existing curriculum or
or Civic instruction uh one of the
concerns is I alluded to earlier is that
yes we have Civic classes but candidly
some schools do better all schools teach
it differently and some some schools and
again my experience in teaching with
three different colleges has been uh
that I I'm concerned that many classes
don't cover some of the the basics so
that no change to curriculum this is
just an assessment that could be
administered at the uh discretion of the
school
district follow up Mr chairman yes go
ahead thank you Mr chairman So based on
that representative if if it's not going
to be something taking out of the
curriculum to fill a time span then it's
could be it's going to be a standalone
test because obviously the
curriculum time in the classroom is
already complete so we have to we can't
add more time so we have to take
something out of the curriculum so if
it's going to be a standalone test it
doesn't necessarily have to be in would
be in service class just a requirement
for high school graduation
period is that correct thank you repr of
uh that's a good question and it
basically it comes down to time
management for example uh you know
sometimes uh gues counselors or whatever
ask teachers to uh administer some sort
of uh questionnaire assessment exam or
whatever and uh is is is required as
comes up and so it's a simple case of
time management I don't think that this
involves uh taking anything out of
existing curriculum whatsoever uh it's
just something that needs to be worked
in in some fashion I I want to leave
that up to uh schools and classes to
integrate uh I think this is a test that
some people can take in 15 minutes
really if they've settled for it they
zip out for it so the the notion of the
concern of this you know preempting
other uh learning uh really is is not
not a significant issue I I not BL Mr
chair I just make one final comment
representative based on that if this is
going to be that high stakes of an
examination the kids cannot graduate
from high school without passing I don't
think there's any school that's going to
just put it aside and give them 15
minutes you move this to the highest
level of the of the
diploma thank
you yes thank you uh I again the schools
can do this they want you know 15
minutes my my point is that many
students will finish in 15 minutes
because it's it's it's not that hard
really for most students uh but no I was
not suggesting that that a class uh
allocate 15 minutes for 100 question
assessment um that that was my point my
point is it's just uh shouldn't take
very much time at all to to
administer thank you very much I have a
question for you representative Mar uh
and it's directed at the intent of this
bill currently under the under current
legislation the school district or
school can administer a locally designed
competency
assessment uh then if they opt not to
use that they may use the citizenship
and the immigration uh test has
developed by the United States
citizenship or by the US
CIS is it your intent that they have to
pass both of those whereas in the past
you if you pass the local test then you
did you know they may not use the other
test or they may opt to use the
citizenship test if they didn't use a
local test now in your legislation
you're asking for the local assessment
test to be passed and the immigration
test is that your intent yes uh Mr chair
that is the intent the intent is that
every student in in New Hampshire uh
have a chance to take and do take this
uh 100 question test uh in addition and
I understand existing statute uh does
have some provision for locally admin
administered tests again the concern is
that some localities do better than
others at uh at these locally developed
instruments or assessments so this
Common Assessment uh which would be
common everybody the intent to your
question is that yes every student take
it and also uh to an earlier question
with regard to I believe was
representative Cornell had asked about
if this applies to uh Charter Schools uh
RSA 189 col11 section one that does
refer to uh requirements like this uh
being applied to all public and and
private schools in the state uh thank
you for your questions thank you very
much uh representative B thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking a
question back to mentioned before about
local control so could be the local
school district decides that we will
make this test as part of our
Civics that also be done sure I think
that uh makes a lot of sense uh again we
want to let the should this move forward
we want to let the districts locally
decide how to implement it but uh Civic
exam uh it's C some government history
is part of this but it's part of a uh
natural
questions
Lake thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
one is just simply actually just a
technical suggestion um you the bill
refers to the 100 question test it's
actually 128 questions as of 2020
not 100 so you you you'll probably need
to change that um I'm still a bit and I
know Mr chairman you asked about this
and I'm still trying to get my head
around this so that there's the idea
here is that the student must pass
two tests one is a sort of or two
assessments one is a competency
assessment that can be developed locally
and the other is the um the immigration
test um and in the past we have allowed
districts to substitute the immigration
test for the local competency locally
designed competency um given those that
are given that that option's been
available do we have any data at
all on how students have done on the
immigration test here in New Hampshire I
don't know how long that requirements or
that that's been in place but I'm just
wondering if we have any data yeah thank
you uh I I do not know
at this time I couldn't tell you the
data in terms of what schools uh do what
assessments so how many already have
have uh utilized this uh naturalization
requirement uh but that's a a very good
point that this came up the last time on
someone asked a similar question about
data and um I I think that if or when
this does become uh a practice a
required practice uh that will give us
data because schools can then tell us
uh you know how many students took the
test how many had to retake it in in
percentages like that in in terms of the
locally developed assessments they're
certainly you know free to do whatever
they've been doing uh in terms of
locally developed assessments there's
been a wide range of those and again
some schools have done much better than
others and again this one would would
just give a common experience to to
every school thank you uh other
questions okay we do have several
several attendees that would uh that are
not on the participant
list panelist list excuse
me okay so bfield are
you there yes can you hear me yes I do
oh perfect uh so for the record my name
is anarie Banfield and I'm an advocate
for parental rights and academic
excellence and education uh today I do
come here in support of HB
320 so I have to ask you how many times
you have seen the man on the street
interviews with adults who cannot answer
basic questions on Civics this is why
Supreme Court Justices so Sonia sodar
and Neil Gorsuch have been advocating
for civics education in schools and
believe that it should be a mandatory
part of the
curriculum for those who continually
talk about supporting P public education
this is a way to do it impr improving
literacy in a core academic subject is
how we all work together to improve
public schools in New Hampshire the test
requires students to know some basic
information on us Civics and HB 320
requires students to receive a passing
grade this test is not a replacement for
a good Civics program and good social
study standards can assist in developing
excellent
curriculum several states have already
enacted laws that require passage of the
test in all schools this would mean that
New Hampshire students would be required
to have the same basis of knowledge in
Civics currently there are no State
standardized tests in New Hampshire on
social studies State standardized tests
and with over and with an overemphasis
on stem and Workforce training our own
Supreme Court Justices are seeing the
problem this has created parents and
community members want to make sure our
kids know how our government works they
want to know when it's student graduates
from high school that they have a basic
understanding of how this country was
founded how it's governed and what it
means to be a citizen a basis of
knowledge is needed in order to engage
in analytical and critical thinking some
public and private schools already use
this in New Hampshire so why not require
this for all
students um Civics today tends to focus
on
action but they should have a foundation
of knowledge know in order to draw upon
in order to take action there is nothing
good about illiteracy especially when it
comes to this
subject uh some of these classes focus
on Project based learning they've moved
away from a real focus on academics and
so would this take some time out of the
classroom possibly but you're talking
about literacy you're talking about
academic content so you're not taking a
t t you know not taking time away from
learning information and knowledge
having that knowledge uh while public
education is moving towards a more stem
in Workforce training Focus there are
good reasons to support equality Liberal
Liberal Arts education liberal comes
from the Latin word liar and it means
free a quality education in the liberal
arts makes one free because it
transforms the students into good adults
and good citizens an education too
focused on employment may make a good
Banker but it won't make a good citizen
and CS Lewis once wrote that if
education is beaten by training
civilization dies the lesson of history
is that Civilization is a rarity
attained with difficulty and easily lost
it is the Liberal Liberal Arts not
vocational training that preserves
Civilization by producing reasonable
citizens we act most human when we are
reasonable in our thoughts and what we
do the liberal arts is a discipline in
education of self-rule to fulfill our
vocation to preserve civilization and to
avoid the errors of the past when we
Elevate literacy in all core subjects
that is good for the students it's good
for public schools and it's good for the
community so for these reasons I ask you
to vote aop pass on HB 320 and I just
like to add that some of these are basic
facts basic information but if we moved
away from teaching math facts would it
be a problem to come back to focus on Ma
math facts I think we can all see the
benefit when uh when we go back to
teaching math facts as especially as a
math tutor myself um and finally if you
want to give the test to the Reps I'm
all for that too so thank you for
listening thank you very much um are
there let's see I think the next person
to speak was Carl lad from the school
administrators
Association good afternoon Carl good
afternoon Mr chairman thank you for um
taking my uh testimony um and um I would
like to thank uh representative Moffett
for his excellent uh instruction when I
was in his ninth grade New Hampshire
history class uh because uh because of
him uh I certainly do understand uh how
government works um and uh he was a
great teacher um having said that um
with all due respect uh to
representative Moffett I'm not really
sure that this is uh a necessary
addition uh to statute um the the the
bill in front of you is focused on
Article 2 of RSA 189
91 but I think that you need to focus on
article one of RSA
189 which states specifically that all
public and private schools in the state
shall be given regular courses of
instruction in the history government
and constitutions of the United States
and New Hampshire including the
organization and operation of New
Hampshire Municipal County and state
governments it goes on to say that a
school district shall develop an offer
the United States and New Hampshire
government Civics course and at a
minimum the course shall include
opportunities and responsibilities for
civic instruction and involvement skills
to effectively participate in civic
affairs the US Constitution the New
Hampshire Constitution the structure and
functions of the three branches of
government the role opportunities and
responsibilities of a citizen to engage
in Civic
activity um last year there was also Al
an addition made to article one stating
how intolerance bigotry anti-Semitism
and National ethnic racial or religious
hatred and discrimination have evolved
in the past such as the Holocaust and
how to prevent the evolution of such
practices so I I would say that um what
uh representative Moffett is trying to
get at a basic knowledge uh is already
built into the
competencies uh identified in statute
for civics
classes um and as a former social
studies teacher and a history teacher
for eth graders uh I certainly can
empathize with folks uh not necessarily
uh understanding how uh government works
and what the three branches of
government
are um I'm not convinced however that
being able to identify uh that the miss
Missippi is one of the longest rivers in
the United States or that the Pacific
Ocean is on the west coast is really
going to get at what representative
Moffet is talking about which is Civic
involvement Civic understanding uh and
Civic engagement um I do believe that
the competencies that have been
identified already in statute do that
and that local school districts are
already using uh parts of that
naturalization exam
as part of their instruction and built
into their competencies um I would just
ask has either representative Moffett or
any of the um the folks on the committee
have you seen any of the locally adopted
uh Civics competencies or the Civics
assessments my sense is that they go
into not only what is outlined in the
naturalization test but goes beyond that
to talk about how do you participate in
your local state and federal governments
because that's expressly laid out in
article one of RSA
189 um so I just think that this adds
one more thing uh to the plate of
Educators um that is
unnecessary um I I think it's a good
thing to be incorporated in some way but
I don't believe that it's necessary as
uh an ultimate assessment or even one of
the ultimate assessments for a high
school uh
competency uh or a Civics course um and
I should just point out too um that
um my my fear is that this type of focus
limits what students will be concent
trting on anybody who has taught in the
classroom knows that if if you are
saying that this is going to be the test
by which you're measured then that's
what students focus on they focus on the
answers to that test how many folks have
passed the driver's test when they were
16 and then blly go out and break every
rule that they just learned about when
they're driving their car uh so I I
think that the
having the knowledge and then being able
to implement it are two different things
um and I think that we do have a good
structure in place uh to provide the
types of things that representative
Moffet is looking for without adding
something additional with that I'll end
my testimony thank you Mr chairman thank
you very much Dr Lad are there any
questions for the school
administrators uh yes represent Hopson
yes thank you for taking my question
again um
Mr lad um do you answer a question are
you confident that all schools are
imparting and succeeding in imparting
the basic Civic
fundamentals yes the the Assumption by
all of us has to be that school
districts are following the law uh that
they are developing curriculum that we
have quality teachers and administrators
overseeing that um do certain districts
have more resources and uh ability to
provide above and beyond yes uh but
certainly
everyone every superintendent that I
know of uh and every building principal
and every High School Civics teacher and
uh Middle School uh Civics teacher uh
understands this law and is working
incredibly hard to implement it and to
make sure that students are engaged and
do understand
um so I my answer is is yes they are
they all being able to provide it at the
same level no because um in one school
district you may have a college
professor uh who's teaching a high
school college or a high school Civics
course because they're retired and have
a doctorate in history and somewhere
else you may have somebody who doesn't
have that background it but the the
content is still being being covered in
the same
way will you take a followup question to
that followup sir hson I I just wanted
to uh point out an experience that I
know was happening in our school
district and I thought it was it was
amazing uh and I wish I had had the
opportunity to do this when I was in
school our students were able to watch
uh
immigrant um students
come in and take the citizenship
citizenship test in a ceremony and I
asked if our students knew the
citizenship test and what was on the
test and if they could pass it and uh I
was told that they're not given that
test so um I just I thought that that
was a disadvantage for them that they're
watching people take become citizens in
our country and and it it's an honor are
you going to pop question
agree uh yes I I do agree that it's an
honor um and I do know that um several
um school districts where there are uh
naturalization um ceremonies that are
conducted within the schools um the the
teachers who are in involved with that
certainly do have their students take
those exams and and are aware of them
and what they look like and what
uh prospective citizens have to do in
order to become a citizen um but I don't
think those those tests aren't uh then
recorded um and put on uh a transcript
they're they're provided to the to those
particular students and I'm not saying
that everyone gets the same experience
uh but and not everyone even if this
gets passed um will get the same
experience uh that your children were
fortunate enough to get um because they
may not have a naturalization Center uh
that's either in location to their
school or um actually some are located
in the
schools thank you very much Dr lad uh
are there any further questions for the
school boards Association not seeing any
hands I'd like to invite uh Megan Tuttle
to
testify I am Lo her go
ahead welcome
Tuttle hello hello chair how are you
sorry about that my thing kicked out
kicked me out again as it did yesterday
um I am here um my name is Megan Tuttle
but I am here testifying as an
individual today not as the president of
Nea New Hampshire I just want want to
make that clear um I taught social
studies for 18 years in 8th grade and I
just came out of the classroom a few
years ago um and while I do like the
intent of this bill because I do agree
with everything that's been said um
especially with um Dr Lad and and
everybody else who spoken the only
concern or one of the concerns I have um
is that it's a little vague and it's not
really clear on when this would be you
know administered the test when it would
be given there's a lot of talk about it
being given in eth grade and that it
wouldn't take time out from the
classroom and I can speak as an
experienced educator of social studies
of 8th grade for 18 years that you know
time is already precious in the
classroom I was teaching about
Washington DC one day a week because we
go visit our nation's capital and on a
field trip and that was important the
kids knew what they were going to see um
I was teaching from the 1800s up through
the path up through after reconstruction
so that took you know a few days I also
took one day a week to talk about um
economics and teach about that because
that's not something that's typically
taught as much so my kids had to get
jobs as if they were high schoolers they
had to learn to um you know balance a
checkbook they had to have a job they
had to put in their hours every week and
they had cards that happened and they
had to be a um you know homeowner so we
did all that it does take time into the
curriculum to do something like this if
it is looking for eth grade um I did
give this immigration test as a test
before they actually could come into my
classroom as eighth graders um we gave
it as kind of the first day of school
for me okay here's the naturalization
test that people get to become um
naturalized citizens of the United
States how would you do on it
and very often they didn't do too well
but then I gave it at the end of the
year as well and you know they did
acquire the knowledge and I would say
over 18 years of teaching most of them
did learn a lot more throughout the year
without a focus on just learning the
facts um that being said I do support
the concept I just think this bill is a
little vague in it I do think that we
need to have much more um Civics taught
in the terms of what it is to become a
citizen and how can you be a productive
citizen in society um you know we do
need to know the history I think a lot
of problems have cropped up in the past
few years past 10 years because there's
been so much focus on Reading Writing
math the stem activities Etc the social
studies has been put aside and it hasn't
been as much of a focus as it should
have been over the years um
so I just wanted to put that out there
um not as president of n New Hampshire
I'm not speaking for the members I'm
speaking as myself an individual um an
educator and a mom of three boys who I
still have to explain things to daily um
and one's in eighth grade right now so
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you very much Miss tutle for your for
your information I think many of us are
past social studies teachers and we tend
to agree exactly I'm another plate
somewhere maybe dessert I don't know but
um at any rate are there any questions
tutle around the neighborhood
here I don't see anybody with questions
I I thank you very much for your
testimony thank you you're
welcome do we have anybody else in the C
see well thank you very much uh
represent Moffet for your bill HB 320 we
are now going to close that hearing
and go to the next bill on that hearing
how many did we have supporting
oppositional
or go ahead six in support oppos there
are six in support and 20 opposed that
you 255
okay uh 255 is up on the dock next uh to
Bild B relative to limited liability for
institutions of higher education and
businesses as the sponsor of that bill I
will hand the G over to represent
pelli thank you Mr chairman uh I will
open the hearing on
h255
and sponsor uh chairman glad thank you
very much uh represent cordelli uh for
the record my name is Rick lad I come
from hav New
Hampshire and I'm here today to speak on
HB
255 uh this bill was brought to my
attention uh by the university system of
New Hampshire and legal staff over there
at the University
system um it occurred early early summer
late spring when we went forward with uh
developing this bill uh I have some
testimony which I'll quickly read so
that will hint the points and get us
done very quickly some 35 business
organizations are behind the newa
business and industry Association in
supporting legislation to back covid-19
liability protections for companies the
university system of New Hampshire has
also active in seeking liability
protections against lawsuits fortunately
to this point no s lawsuits have
occurred but it only takes one in a
recent article in a New Hampshire
Business Review those supporting similar
legislation of this type included the
national Federation of Independent
businesses New Hampshire Bankers
Association the New Hampshire Automobile
Dealers Association the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association New
Hampshire Motor Transport Association
New Hampshire college and university
Council New Hampshire Hospital
Association New Hampshire Medical
Society New Hampshire school boards
Association ski New Hampshire and
numerous Chambers of Commerce this light
legislation is proposed today is the
first step in creating a liability sh
shield for protection against lawsuits
during declared emergencies such as
covid-19 legislation such as this create
some level of predictability and
confidence so that people can move
forward
here parents students and business
owners along with other decision makers
can make appropriate decisions that
often diverge from what was once normal
in regard to higher education there is
no consensus about how a college campus
life will occur or uniformally or or
uniformity in calendar or fiscal matter
matters associated with Co out our hand
there are so many plans as there are
institutions and their guide books are
being written in pencil leading families
and students sort of in limbo at times
this past July more than 800 faculty at
Georgia Tech signed a letter opposing a
decision by the State Board of regions
to forbid public universities from
requiring face masks families and
students aren't all convinced that
online classes should cost the same as
taking them in in a bricks and morar
campus the path this path frames defish
def home through lawsuits from families
who wanted tuition discounts and refunds
saying that they didn't get what they
paid for a few schools including
Williams College Georgetown University
Princeton University and Spelman College
have cut their tuition for the year with
some giving discounts of remote learning
and in some cases even for students
returning to campus within a new within
New Hampshire the university system uh
saw a higher rate of freshman failing
first year courses this past year some
institutiones in New Jersey and
Massachusetts are looking for protection
from lawsuits if student athletes fall
ill at school while participating in
these activities Ohio State and others
have required students athletes to sign
waivers clearing the school from Fall if
they got sick when returning for
voluntary workouts this fill places a
limitation on liability for an
institution of higher education or
business for per for personal injury
resulting from or related to the actual
or alleged exposure to Corona virus
covid-19 no business or Higher Education
Institute or individual employed by a
business shall be liable for personal Li
for personal injury resulting from or
related to the actual alleged exposure
to Corona virus or covid-19 in the
course of such institution's
activity this condition shall not apply
to any person personal injury from or
related to the actual or Alle alleged
Expos exposure to Corona virus or
covid-19 if the individual alleging the
inj injury proves by clear and convicing
evidence that injuries were caused by
the businesses or higher education
institutions a gross negligence willful
misconduct intentional criminal
misconduct or intentional infliction of
harm so in conclusion uh this has been
brought forward by the university system
uh they're they're looking to have this
Shield hopefully they won't have to be
use it but it is a protection for the
University all the staff within it and
the businesses as well and the state of
New Hampshire thank you very much for
the opportunity to testify on this
Bill thank you Mr
with m
m
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question represent lad why
just the higher
education why wouldn't we have public
schools that would also be included in
this particular uh piece of uh proposal
because they've got the same potential
liability as a higher education
they I'm I'm not really a represent I'm
not an attorney but uh this was written
by the university system and opened up
the
businesses uh because it mimics
legislation that was proposed on the
Congressional level in Washington DC uh
and it's similar to uh the many business
and industry associations throughout the
country in terms of dealing with k
through2 for example we're dealing with
a situation there where you also dealing
with minors you're not dealing with
adults as you would be on the other two
fronts
so would would you be opposed to would
you be opposed to putting public schools
in there I I'm I'm not opposed to trying
to get a liability Shield like this for
any group that there is open to uh it
could possibly happen on on the K
through2 level as well there's a lot of
act activity occurring where there's
some folks very disgruntled about their
students not going to school every day
of the week being home three days a week
uh and on the various it's scheduling is
like at the colleges it's different for
every place you go than thank
you thank you representative
committee sorry thank you Mr chair um I
not sure if there'll be a lawyer
speaking on this later I don't know if I
can ask a question there but I guess uh
chairman lad or Mr representative lad
since I guess you're not in that seat
right now um the language on um having
to fall rely on applicable government
standards and guidance um while it is
just limited to to covid here that seems
like a really large barn door that could
be opened up I don't know if some
language that would cover the idea that
if anybody were to willfully deceive
anybody about their M risk mitigation
efforts might be um a solution that
would protect them because as long as
they're willing to discuss whatever
mitigation they're taking to approach Co
which may be above and beyond the
guidelines it'll prevent us from uh
basically being an enforcement arm of uh
of departments as opposed to having
those laws come from the legislature yes
when we introduce this
ran um it's it's basically a close to a
boiler plate from many places throughout
the country you could go to Montana and
probably find similar legislation
as a result of the University Systems
and business uh uh working together
trying to and and on the Congressional
level as well this bill would have to go
before a second
committee most likely Judiciary right
and where where we have legal staff that
would provide the type of answers to
medicate some of the issues that that
will probably come up as a result of
this I know that there probably will be
uh very ious uh Judiciary groups may be
testifying today I haven't seen the list
I talked to one the other night on the
horn I think the intent is there the
intent is a good intent however there
probably going to be a lot of legal
ramifications and with this being a very
high priority I think it was Priority
One when I went to the Bia meetings this
this fall for that
organization um and I know the
university although they may not have
had any issues like this and business
may be the same it's that one issue that
may come up so uh it's something that
should be worked on should probably go
to Judiciary we're talking Co here we
could be talking about some other
emergency just as well and how would
this apply to that so there I think this
is just a start and I guess it's trying
to be a little proactive rather than
reactive later on thank you very much
for the question thank you very much
thank you any further questions yes Mr
representative W thank you Mr chairman
um representative L just f up uh uh on
the liability for
institutions uh just as a and I think
you may have just answered saying that
you don't know the answer uh because you
go to different Judiciary committees but
uh for the college setting if uh one of
our colleges uh is having a
organizational meeting or an
organizational a a rally if you will uh
and students are participating in the
rally and they are
unmasked and there's a massive number of
people beyond the governor's order
they're unmasked and someone gets covid
from the unmasked group and then passes
away and the university did not stop the
stop the the uh rally uh or could be a
local Bender downtown next to University
if they did not stop the rally uh or
enforce the masking regulation would
that would this then allow them to be
exempt the the issues you raised
representative are perhaps not through
the degree but sort of similar to
remember the fraternity incident at the
beginning of Co here at UNH that was in
the paper 40 plus kids got together and
of the 40 plus kids we had a high number
of kids that came down with Co we've
been down there for um our session days
several times to the UNH campus and I
thank them very much for the opportunity
of being there however there are times
when I noticed that there were people
that were uh walking around without mask
and that kids were quick to identify and
try to say why aren't you wearing your
mask there are situations where um if
the
University Systems knly allowing this to
occur and allowing and sanctioning that
party at the fraternity house knowing
all the circumstances and the issues
associated with covid are they going to
be responsible I think I'm getting into
the turf of a lawyer and I don't want to
go there but Common Sense would say that
the university has responsibility to the
all the students they're paying tuition
to provide a safe environment and I know
that the university system theh is doing
that um so uh I think we're talking
about where's that line that's where I
would say that it needs really some
Judiciary Committee work um this is I'm
looking at from the policy perspective
saying yes it's good intent perhaps we
ought to be looking into this this area
of
concern thank you Mr chairman morning
wel thank
youan has question
that
yes thank you Mr chair um I was
wondering uh Mr lad um if representative
lad if um the university has liability
insurance where uh they
have uh policy and also risk management
and also um policies in place uh
prescribed by the insurance company to
avoid um
problems and then Insurance to back it
up if it does happen for Co thank you
for the question represent Tanner as a
trustee for the University system uh I
have the opportunity to work with Tom
Cronin who is their public relations SL
part of the uh the legal council
division of the University system I
don't have the answer for you at this
time but I'd be pleased to try to seek
you thank you not see any further
questions from the committee um we will
come on to our next
uh Israel Pedro representative Pedra oh
Manchester thank you Mr chair and the
committee I appreciate the time to
testify today um I'm testifying an
opposition of this bill uh as the
chairperson said I am a representative I
represent Ward 2 in Manchester and I'm
also a lawyer um a practicing attorney
and part of my practice is representing
folks injured due to negligence um I
also have
experience uh considerable experience
with certain immunity statutes which
exist currently um such as this one
particularly the the ski immunity
statute so I'm somewhat qualified on
this topic um I'm opposed to this bill
for for a simple reason um regardless of
of what other other explanations are
proferred the sole purpose and the sole
effect of this bill is to allow
negligent businesses and negligent
colleges which negligently injure
someone to get off scot-free that is
100% the only effect of this bill um and
why is that because under current law a
college or business and I I I say both
because because I think the the chairman
really only mentored universities but
this bill actually Cuts much broader
than that it also includes businesses
generally um Pro for-profit businesses
under current law those entities are
only responsible they're only legally
liable if they're negligent you're not
liable someone gets injured or covid on
your property just you know just on your
property you're not liable if one of
your employees gives covid to one of
your customer customers um you're only
liable if you are negligent and so what
this statute or what this bill does is
to immunize negligent
behavior
um there's a couple exceptions in here
um that that you know create exceptions
to this immunity bar to negligence one
and I'll go through a couple things here
in the in the bill one is that it
creates an exception for grossly
negligent conduct um in paragraph two or
three here um however I'll I'll just
point out that the way that it defines
gross negligence is not in accord with
the common law it's not in accord with
the law um well in New Hampshire we
actually don't recognize degrees of
negligence but the law generally
elsewhere um the definition of gross
negligence here would require an injured
person to prove that a the business or
college knew the others were likely to
catch the virus but acted anyway not
that not just that they should have
known um you have to actually under this
bill prove that person's state of mind
and that they consciously disregarded an
extreme risk it's basically an
impossible standard um and it's it's
really just window dressing um it it
really does not create any sort of
workable uh allowance for bringing a
meritorious claim for personal injury if
there were any such claim and I think
that's something we cannot Closs over at
all it's one of the first things that
chairman lad said and he
acknowledged there has been no covid
personal injury claim in New Hampshire
period there's no evidence of any
lawsuit in that regard or any other
legal claim this is not a problem um
we're almost a year into this thing
we're getting better at managing it and
still even from the beginning of this
pandemic there has not been a single
legal claim in New Hampshire relating to
it that's pretty striking and and it
kind of reveals to me how this is
unnecessary and how it really has a uh
an intent much broader than the innocent
purpose that it it it's purported to be
um the next thing that the bill does is
it raises the standard of proof so not
only can you not recover even if the
business or college is negligent even if
you try to prove gross negligence or or
wanting contact or whatever the other
ceptions are it creates a standard of
proof Which is higher than what's normal
for civil trials in New Hampshire and
anywhere else in the country which is
the preponderance of the evidence
standard um the standard that's been in
place for centuries in this country it
changes that standard to clear and
convincing which is a higher burden of
proof a very difficult burden of proof
to demonstrate um so even again even if
you could show gross negligence under
nor normal circumstances which I think
would be virtually impossible under the
standard you still don't Prevail you
still have to meet this higher even
higher more rigorous standard um and
finally if that weren't enough the bill
shortens the standard of the statute of
limitations which is three years in New
Hampshire to one year um so not only do
you have this nearly impossible standard
to me of gross negligence not only do
you have a higher burden of proof than
every other civil litigant in the state
you also have onethird of the time to
bring a claim even if you can meet all
all of those uh standards so you know
this is simply speaking an completely
unnecessary thing um it's there's no
evidence that it that it is required to
protect
businesses um you know the the chairman
mentioned that it only takes one and I
would ask it only takes one until what
and the world is not going to end if
there's a claim
um if there is a claim I think we can
assume at this point that it has some
Merit because we've gone almost a year
and there hasn't been any rash of
frivolous
lawsuits um the entire purpose of the
Judiciary System and our justice system
is to allow folks to bring their claims
into court and have a jury of their
peers decide whether that claim is valid
you know that system has worked for
hundreds of years what our framers
intended our founding fathers and what
this bill does is essentially have the
legislature dictate who gets access to
the courthouse it's an activist it's a
paternalistic it's an unnecessary
measure um and really all it does is is
protect negligent conduct um I'll I'll
also add just as a side um and aside
that we're as one of the representatives
mentioned we're we're really talking
about insurance companies here um it's
insurance companies spending the money
to if there is such a claim to defend it
to pay a settlement or to pay a verdict
um and finally it's not going to
prevent uh cases from being filed in the
first place that's something I've heard
some proponents say yeah they couldn't
prove it under current law but we still
have to pay to defend it um that's going
to be the case anyway even with this
bill passed even if there were a
unmeritorious claim Advanced there's
exceptions under the statute and they
could a lawyer or a plantiff could still
Advance a lawsuit under those exceptions
so you're going to defend it either way
all this bill does is immunize negligent
conduct so I'm happy to take any
questions um but that's why I oppose
this
Bill thank you representative first
question is from representative Miler uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative for bringing this forward
is there a this may be an impossible
answer but is there a simple definition
of
negligence
yes it's the fail failure to use
reasonable care under all the
circumstances and it's purposefully a
flexible
definition um what is a reasonable care
under the circumstances depends
obviously on the circumstances so if
you're driving a car and you fail to
stop at a stop
light we Define that as a failure to use
reasonable care um in this situation if
you are a business owner and you're a
you know you're aware of the risk of
covid in the community and the the rates
are rising and you failed to take any
measures to you know mitigate that risk
or prevent customers from being exposed
to that risk then a jury would have to
decide is it reasonable for that jury
for that business to act the way it did
and I think in many cases a jury is
going to understand that this is a very
difficult Dynamic situation businesses
can't
guarantee a customer's safety or
colleges can't guarantee a student
safety and a jury I think in many cases
would conclude yes despite fact that
someone got injured due to covid on the
property or whatever despite the fact
they may have been able to do more they
acted reasonably and therefore there's
no negligence and therefore there's a
verdict for the defense um so that's why
the existing common law and the existing
state of the law now is flexible enough
to handle a lot of the concerns brought
by proponents of this bill the standard
adapts and it has adapted for hundreds
of
years thank you very
much thank you um I see representative
Muffet thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent for taking my question uh in
terms of torts or personal injuries
those cases happen all the time and it's
often very easy to prove negligence or
gr's negligence or who's in fall
but with co uh even if a a university
has bad practices or Del is delinquent
in in some
practices isn't it true that there is
absolutely no way to prove that anyone
ever got a virus here or there it may be
likely but isn't it impossible to prove
that anyone got a virus
anywhere I think that's absolutely
correct representative thank you for
that question and that illustrates very
well why this is unnecessary because
under the current law a plaintiff would
need to prove not only that a business
was negligent or a college was negligent
in some way but also that the person who
contracted the virus contracted it more
likely than not from that business or
college um so under current law I would
say that it's difficult if not
impossible for a plaintiff to prove that
they contracted covid from a negligent
actor um all this bill would do is if in
a certain case it were
provable that someone caught covid you
know as a as a more likely than not
reasonable likelihood um from a
particularly negligent
actor that under this bill they still
would not be able to bring a claim um I
can imagine some hypothetical situations
where you could prove more likely than
not that someone contracted covid from a
particular actor if someone literally
did not leave their home except to go to
a business for for one thing and caught
covid I think a jury could conclude more
likely than not they caught it from that
Source but as you say that's extremely
unlikely people go out into the
community they interact with other
people and I think in 99.9% of cases you
would not be able to prove that to a
unnecessary thank you yes represent oh
thank you Mr chair uh I do understand
that in most cases you couldn't prove
the transmission but would this be a
huge problem for nursing homes where
facility I'm not sure I understand your
question what do you mean by what would
it be a huge problem well would this
would this open up I guess you're
talking about about the challenge of
showing the transmission in any location
but with this higher burden of proof a
patient who's been in a nursing home
since January 1st 2020 would have no
other rout of transmission other than
the nursing home correct and so so this
is that's one of the few P clear cases
where you could prove
transmission I think you're right
arguably um I think a defense would
still argue well they had you know they
were interacting with vendors who
weren't employees of the Nur ing home or
they were interacting with other
patients who interacted with vendors
there's all sorts of um you know with an
a virus nature this one is or any um
threat or risk such as this one you can
always argue potentially that it came
from other sources but you're right
that's one of the few situations where I
could conceivably see um a jury say yeah
we can we can we have a reasonable
likelihood um that more likely than not
this is where the plaintiff contracted
covid they were clearly negligent in
some way and therefore they should be
held responsible um under this bill even
if you could show that that nursing home
patient
was uh did contract covid from the
nursing home from the nursing home's
negligence and that you know they died
or were harmed as a result under this
bill that person would have no recourse
under the
law thank you very much thank you Mr
thank you um I ask one question um what
happens when a college allows students
to walk around campus without masks if
the college does in fact have a mask
policy but it doesn't enforce
it sure so I think that goes back to the
centuries old standard of reasonableness
and negligence there isn't any require
enironment that a business or college
take literally every measure possible to
prevent a risk there's no requirement
that um they make their campus perfectly
safe as long as they're taking some sort
of reasonable precautions such as you
know having an you know I think what the
colleges are doing right now is
reasonable frankly which is have a
mandate you know have certain uh
enforcement you know at at reasonable
areas and reasonable buildings you can't
police every single student out on
campus you can't police every single
person in their dorms and I think that a
jury would agree as long as they're
taking good faith efforts they've acted
reasonably and therefore there is no
negligence so I don't think that there
would be liability under current law for
massless students walking
around thank you um I see no further
questions for the representative thank
you very much for being here this
afternoon thank you very much next we
have Carol Martin Carol i' promoted you
yourself where did you go there you are
right here good afternoon
hi um hi I'm Carol Martin I'm the
associate general counsel for the
University system and um I appreciate
the opportunity to speak on this bill um
we are grateful to the sponsors of this
bill and representative lad for bringing
it forward to this committee um and for
considering the issues of liability
related to
covid-19 if the pandemic has taught us
anything and is that we cannot predict
what tomorrow will bring and just based
on the comments I've heard so far that
includes um the the changes and
regulations and expectations and what is
considered reasonable during this time U
from the onside the university system
trans transitioned quickly to remote
learning to support our hosts and
surrounding communities and to assist in
the state's response to the
pandemic over the summer we developed
and implemented plans for weekly testing
and well-coordinated safety measures
which include mask mandates that allowed
us to return over 20,000 students from
around the state and across the country
to in-person learning on our campuses
this past fall these efforts were
necessary despite their expense to
ensure that we had engaging learning
experiences and to protect our students
faculty and staff and to provide vital
support to the local economies and the
communities that host our
institutions systemwide and systematic
testing has helped to decrease Community
spread by identifying asymptomatic cases
that may have otherwise gone undetected
we are incredibly proud of our students
and our staff and faculty who have
embraced a culture of safety
accountability and care for one another
possible right now we're at the
beginning of our spring semester at UNH
in Plymouth State and we have um Keen
State starting in a couple of weeks our
students and faculty are engaged in a
range of learning modalities while our
Frontline campus employees including
Dining Services residential life student
support staff are all working in person
and on campus um diligently to ensure a
safe engaging and productive
semester we've worked hard to meet and
exceed federal and state
recommendations and guidelines and again
I would add that those change almost
daily and certain certainly
frequently and we've been Guided by the
best available research to to open and
operate our campuses safely our testing
program has provided evidence for the
success of these efforts as rates of
infection on our campuses have remained
well below the state
average with that said the current
Public Health crisis continues to
present us with new and untested
circumstances given the uncertainty as
we welcome a conversation around
liability protection in order to attempt
to ensure that our institutions and our
faculty and staff are protected and I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee see none um I thank you very
much for your testimony have a good
afternoon thank you we have next we have
Rudolph Ogden and I've promoted you so
you should just unmute yourself thank
you uh good afternoon uh thank you for
allowing me to speak for the record my
name is Rudy Ogden Deputy Commissioner
of the Department of Labor I just wanted
to speak Bri uh briefly this bill does
reference intersection with RSA 281a
which is the workers comp law and the
state of New Hampshire and we have had
questions uh surrounding workers
compensation and its relation to covid
particularly in the context of workplace
injuries uh for employees uh just as a
brief background I would say and there
is an attorney general's memo to this
effect stating that employees in the
context of uh working for their employer
any injuries that they have resulting
from such activity or actions they are
limited to redress through workers
compensation and what I mean by that is
if an employee is injured or in this
case came down with covid at work and
had certain after effects or impacts
from that condition uh they would not be
able to sue their employer regardless of
these standards such as negligence and
other things of that nature I just point
that out to again stress the fact that
an employee sole recours is through
workers comp that's something that I
don't know that all individuals have an
understanding of uh so it's something
that we try to make clear that for
purposes of immunity or shielding
relative to employees working in the
workplace uh their sole recourse is
through workers compensation uh
additionally uh surviving spouses or
surviving dependent sole recourse would
be through workers compensation and then
just lastly again being mindful of your
time one thing that we had wanted to
point out was just the scope of this at
least for our limited slice and again
I'm only talking about employees in the
context of workers comp but I went back
and looked through uh basically starting
at March one I know that uh it's not
easy to precisely pin when Co started or
where it started or anything of that
nature but just going back to March 1st
of 20120 uh to present date we've had
about 35,000 workplace injuries reported
of those workplace injuries reported
roughly 3,200 of them have had some
designation of covid uh so that's to say
that we've received notice uh what we
would call a first report of injury in
3,200 instances that uh perhaps covid
was happening just one thing I would
note is a first report of in uh first
report of injury is not an indication
that it's an accepted claim and it's not
an acknowledgement by the employer that
covid was definitively determined to
have been caused by work I just point
out that we have had those notices of
injuries lastly in term terms of context
or scope and scale one thing I would
point out is to date we've had six
hearings uh dealing with uh
determinations on whether uh workers
compensation benefits such as Indemnity
or medical bills had to be provided for
dealing with covid as the noted injury
we've had six of those hearings to date
um and we've had one Hearing in which
there was a
determination that the covid was uh an
injury resolving or resulting out of
work I do take note of the fact and I
think it was a very good comment uh that
proving CO's tie or CO's Genesis being
from work or from a particular place is
difficult ult um I don't think that
that's something that's an easy case to
make uh but again we've had one case in
which that case was made and there was a
determination so I'm happy to take any
questions and I would just acknowledge
up front that my purview is limited to
workers compensation and the reason we
decided to speak on this bill was just
the fact that in paragraph 7B there was
specific reference to the fact that
nothing here was to impact or uh undo
questions yes thank you could you please
state your name again I'm sorry no
apologies if I wasn't clear uh my name
correct any further
testimony thank you next we have Marissa
Chase from the asso assciation for
coming
Chase
there she
is
hi I believe you're
muted
see let me see if this works your
a your
but you can hear me okay I apologize
that's all to say I would like to um if
if I may defer my time to attorney Tony
scullen brini who has a hearing at 3M so
if he could go before me that would be
greatly
that okay Mr spell
andini you are just have to unmute
yourself thank
you hello
hi
welcome my name is Anthony scullen brini
I'm a lawyer in nashwa and I am opposed
to this bill I want I to give the
members of the committee a couple of uh
explanations about things that that have
come up in the past one of the things
that was mentioned at the outset was
immunity for certain universities I
happen to be from Ohio Ohio state is a
core part of the identity of every
person from Ohio uh especially Ohio
State football it's really hard to draw
comparisons between universities like
that and the state of New Hampshire for
example if Ohio state was a city in New
Hampshire it would be the third largest
city in the state it's bigger than
conquered by about 20,000 people so the
idea that those sorts of states with
those sorts of uh populations and levels
of exposure to covid should be informing
how the New Hampshire legislature
creates bills I don't think that's a
fair comparison a couple of other things
that I wanted to point out when uh
representative Pedra was talking about
negligence it's important to remember
what lawyers would have to prove in
court to show negligence so negligence
is as he said acting below the standard
of Care Act not using reasonable care
but the lawyers have to prove that there
was a duty of care owed to the person
that the conduct of the defendant
breached that duty of care and most
importantly for determinations of of
liability under covid that that breach
of Duty caused the harm so it's not
simply the case that you could go to
court and Prevail on a claim where you
know there as come up a couple times
students were walking around a
University campus and not wearing masks
and then somebody on the other side of
Campus got covid you'd have to show a
link between that behavior the the way
that behavior would breach not this
those other students but the
University's duty of care and then you
would have to tie those together with
some sort of almost certainly Med
medical testimony to show that there was
a link in terms of causation um the
other things that I wanted to point out
about the Bell is that the standard of
proof and a burden of proof are two
different things so that the burden of
proof is sort of how much stuff you have
to carry and the standard of proof is
how high you have to carry that stuff
and in both cases they are defined in
ways that are really unprecedented in
civil law in the state of New Hampshire
gross NE negligence is almost never the
standard and the system has worked quite
well as uh representative Pedra has
pointed out for Centuries with just the
regular NE negligence standard uh second
on the St uh the burden of or that was
the burden of proof on the standard of
proof clear and convincing evidence is
generally used in places where the state
wants to commit people that is take away
their freedom and hold them such as when
they're committed for mental health
issues to the New Hampshire hospital so
having that as a as the bird as the
standard of proof in a case like this
where the lawyer is you know exploring
these new medical issues that raised by
covid and the person that he's
representing is already sick and injured
I think that both of those things are
unprecedented and far too high one thing
that the representative from the
University mentioned that I want to
point out was this idea of changing uh
changing recommendations and there's no
one that's going to doubt that the CDC
has come out with new and ever changing
recommendations about how covid should
be handled but that's simply the way
that science works and the law has had a
lot of experience dealing with new and
emerging science if you look back at the
litigation surrounding water pollution
or if you look back at the litigation
surrounding asbest these are things that
the the law is equipped to handle and
they deal with it very well and they
have dealt with it very well for at
least a hundred years now that we've had
sort of scientifically informed
litigation and while the standards
change
the the the standard for holding
somebody liable which is what
representative P represent referenced
about reasonable care that doesn't
change and that allows the court to take
into account these updated um
recommendations such as how to deal with
co uh I think that it's also important
to point out that whether you're a
liberal or conservative that immunities
are the kind of things that the law give
uh gives rise to unintended consequences
in the law I'm sure that no one one that
sponsored the internet service provider
bill that provided immunity for uh
online platforms thought that it would
have an impact on the political
discourse uh later on you know 10 or 15
years down the line the reality is when
you bake an immunity into the law you
are all but guaranteeing un unintended
consequences and then finally I do think
that there is a possibility that by
setting the standard so high setting the
burden of proof so high in other words
it's more than mere negligence that what
would end up happening is it would put
the mom and popop businesses that are
sort of tacked onto this education bill
in an odd spot that is that they could
have an insurance policy that covers
negligent acts but because the standard
of the burden of proof is defined so
high here that they would they would
fall out of insurance coverage and would
actually be worse for them than it would
be if the standard of proof was or the
burden of proof was lower in other words
if the burden of proof is gross
negligence or hire and the liability
policy says we only cover negligent acts
then when they get sued the insurance
company could simply walk away and leave
them to their own devices and for those
reasons I oppose this bill and I think
that you should not vote for it and I'm
willing to take any questions anybody
might
have thank you very much do I see any
questions from the committee I do not
believe uh you have any questions thank
you for your time you get on to your
next piece of business next thank you
thank you go back to I was questioning
back thank you very much Representatives
um I would actually ask that you you
defer um to the other attorneys first I
take up a lot of their um billable hours
for free by asking them to testify in
front of the legislature and they have I
I am actually paid to be at this hearing
so I am more than happy to go towards
the end of the hearing hearing and I
appreciate if that's possible I know
Rory Parnell for example also has a
hearing at 3 I apologize I'm sorry did
she say the name what was the name uh
Rory Parnell okay I don't see I don't
see him on on the testify list but okay
call Mr Carnell um your your next
hello I assume you all can hear me yes
thank you well thank you uh chair and
thank you to the committee for taking
the time uh to listen to us uh I
testifying an opposition of this bill
and primarily I'm focused on the
constitutionality of this for those that
have been around long enough there was a
medical malpractice statute p uh many
years ago that included a uh reduction
in the statute of limitations including
uh in addition to that a provision that
affected the evidentiary burden as it
related to
experts and the Supreme Court ended up
taking up this case or taking up that
statute on appeal and found the statute
unconstitutional and I think there is
significant concern that this bill as
written uh limiting the statute of
limitations and and increasing the uh
standard of negligence could result in
this bill being overturned is
unconstitutional and the case was Carson
V
Moore the the problem as noted in that
case
was the Statute uh without providing any
uh additional caveat to Simply
restricted the statute of limitations
without more and the the uh Court the
Supreme Court found that this was
unconstitutional and reversed that that
provision now the the court in that case
examined article one and two of our
constitution equal protection clause
which are obviously uh huge parts of our
uh Foundation of our government but the
other thing that it's important to at
least reference with these immunity
bills is they are taking away the right
of jury trial
in the state of New Hampshire and I I
want to point out one of the the
statements in article 20 um of our state
constitution on the Bill of Rights where
it talks about the jury trial and civil
causes and there's some very interesting
language there that I've always found
fascinating that um our Founders and the
drafters of our state constitution used
and in that provision they say in
referencing the jury trial right they
say this method or procedure shall be
held sacred sacred that is a very
important use of that term because it
provides a higher standard in using that
language as far as what a right of a
citizen is to seek redress in the courts
of New Hampshire and this immunity bill
will abgate that right under article 20
and reduce access to jury trials for
those
that would potentially be injured and I
want to Echo one of the things that
representative Pedra referenced is that
despite this occurring for over a year
this pandemic that has had such a a
detrimental effect on our economy and
our citizens and frankly our psyches
there have been no zero cases involving
injuries with covid and this bill is a a
solution in search of a problem um
so when you are considering this bill
it's important to factor in what is the
foundation of our rights especially as
what I affectionately call a Libertarian
state that we are that allows the
freedom of our citizens that other
states simply don't provide and this
bill will chip away at those rights of
our citizens to seek address in the
courts and really based on it is how it
is currently DED drafted there is real
risk uh that this bill will just be
overturned as unconstitutional because
it violates those sacred Clauses of our
Constitution and so as you consider the
passing of this bill or the rejection of
this bill we ask that you vote against
it because it is unconstitutional as
written and in front of a court that uh
respects our libertarian principles and
respects what is a sacred jury right uh
it it serves a substantial chance of
being overturned just like the uh
malpractice bill was so many years ago
and one uh clarification point I know
this was mentioned um uh the standard of
gross negligence it's important to note
that New Hampshire does not have a
common law gross negligence standard uh
specifically it is only provided for by
Statute uh so common law is case law so
we do not have a gradient of negligence
in the state we uh have a basic
negligence standard as uh representative
pader has noted has been uh successful
and reasonable for hundreds of years and
it is important to note that this
actually would go beyond the current
case law and establish uh gross
negligence that is not present currently
so so this bill is really a solution in
search of a problem again there are no
pending cases and moving up to statute
of limitations and changing the standard
of care really presents uh
constitutional problems to this statute
uh should it be passed and uh we I I
certainly uh am of the position that
this uh should not be passed and should
be rejected I'm happy to take any
questions thank youne Corell any
I see none so thank you very much for
being thank you very much for your
time okay next we'll call um Mr Bill
Woodberry uh I hope you're prepared to
notic hi can you hear me okay yes you
can thank
you
there I am
sorry uh thank you very much uh for
allowing me to speak today uh yes my
name is Bill Woodbury and I am a civil
litigation attorney practicing in lonia
New Hampshire and I also serve as
legislative chair for the New Hampshire
Association for justice um the reality
today is that Israel Pedra
representative Pedra um attorney skull
brini and attorney part
have have framed the issues and and um
explained them exceedingly well and um I
Echo the all the the sentiments that
they've put forth I guess in in the
interest of of time and and being
succinct here as to you know what some
of the arguments are against this and I
am arguing in
opposition um I guess I would just uh
emphasize um one other aspect of this
and that is the Practical realities of
if a case like this were to you know
come into my office or and I'm certainly
not speaking for all attorneys but you
know uh it were were to come into I
think the the average civil litigators
office and that's that um as attorney
scol bini indicated um we're going to
explain to a potential client that you
you're going to need to prove um to a
unanimous jury
that
someone um that a business or an entity
acted unreasonably and that this
unreasonable conduct was what caused the
harm what caused the the infection and
subsequent issues surrounding that and
that is going to be exceedingly
difficult in in every situation with
respect to to
covid-19 um and you know just because
someone someone contracted covid-19 in a
particular place doesn't mean that that
business or entity was a bad actor or
you know should be subject to a finding
of liability um that conduct must be
unreasonable um another practical
reality that people should be aware of
is that because most individuals you
know don't have the money to pay out of
pocket for legal fees um and and the
average personal injury matter or in a
case like this these things are handle
handled on a contingent fee basis and
it's the attorney
who uh fronts the the money for things
like medical experts and in a covid-19
case you're going to have possibly
numerous medical experts you might have
doctors and Physicians that were
actually treating the patient you're
going to have um epidemiologists you're
going to have experts with respect to to
transmission and um this is going to be
exceedingly expensive so the combination
of the likely difficulty in proving that
um The Entity to be sued acted on
unreasonably and caused you know the the
actual injury or illness um that
combined with the the need to you know
make upfront expenditures which may be
exorbitant in these cases makes it very
unlikely these cases um are going to be
brought attorney Parnell is correct this
is essentially a solution in search of a
problem um to date um Nationwide it's
our understanding that there is there
are approximately 400 cases Nationwide
after more than 26 million cases and
four and more than
450,000 deaths um these cases aren't
happening they're not happening in New
Hampshire and um I would come back to
the the point that all the attorneys
especially attorney Parnell has made is
that this this is generally an
unconstitutional act to create
immunities like this immunities breed
irresponsibility and they really have no
place in our body of laws um with that I
would take any questions the panel may
have very
much questions I see one
fromer start uh thank you Mr chair uh
and thank you for taking my question I
don't believe this has been asked yet
but isn't my understanding that there is
a limited
liability uh for hospitals and uh First
Responders uh regarding this how does if
they have that how does that relate to
what's being proposed in this particular
Bill yes sir it's my understanding and I
believe that back in April of 2020 there
was an attorney general opinion that um
the immunities provided in RSA 21 p41
apply to Emer entities um engaged in
Emergency Management activities um uh I
will I I don't know the exact status of
that I believe that that that is renewed
at this point but there's certainly been
actions taken to provide for that so uh
we can certainly um you know submit you
know any additional information on that
question be happy to do that for you sir
but um yes I believe there are
Protections in place thank you thank you
represent
Tanner thank you Mr chair um I have a
question about the the communicable
disease itself the fact that covid-19 is
is listed in this bill and we know it's
you know viruses mutate um may even have
a different name number to it um and
there's other communicable diseases as
well does this bill narrowly uh very
virus it thank you for the question um
representative Tanner uh the bill would
appear as I read it if if we look at
page one lines four and five um uh
pertaining to limited liability for
institutions of higher education for
personal uh injury resulting from a
relating to covid-19 I believe the
specificity is there with respect to
covid-19 but that's not to say that
doesn't set a generally bad precedent
forward thank you very much I see no
further questions so U thank you very
much for being here I thank you for
speak okay thank you next next we have
um Chris sfort from sfor
law good afternoon can you all hear
me thank you um for the record my name
is Christopher sufit from sufit La I
practice here in Franklin New Hampshire
I've been practicing since
1984 it's a general practice
representing many businesses as well as
injured individuals and
Families my business own is similar to
the bia's own survey at dealing with a
whole host of issues we're dealing with
revenue losses we're dealing with
employee retention we're dealing with
child care issues employees working
remotely that's the problem that we're
dealing with my businesses are not
dealing with none of my business clients
have come to me and said we're
threatened of being sued we are being
sued we're worried about being sued
that's not the questions they're asking
me they're asking me all of these other
questions I have had no individuals or
families come to me and say they're
exploring the possibility of bringing a
covid-19 lawsuit against anybody I've
had no experience with that and I've
been doing a lot of
cases what I would like to say is what I
had the privilege of in
2012 arguing to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court the Tom Morgan case
and there's some language in that case
that the Supreme Court emphasized in New
Hampshire what is the very moral fabric
of civilized society and here's the
words they
used responsibility for personal
malfeasance runs through all relations
of
individuals each of us to the
other that is the New Hampshire
way this this bill would remove that
moral
Fabric and would remove the reasonable
standard that we owe each to the other I
ask that this bill not be passed and I'm
happy to take any
thee none I thank you very much for your
testimony thank you okay uh at this time
um we'll Circle back to Marissa Chase
and if Miss Chase if you're all set
we've got one last testifier but I'm not
sure what your plans
were um thank you very much members of
the committee thank you for allowing us
so much of your time I apologize for the
this being in the dark here on my screen
you're just missing my sleeping dog
behind me um but for the record my name
is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice um we are a
Statewide Association of trial attorneys
we have about 400 members Statewide as
New Hampshire is a small state with a
collegial bar our members practice
anything everything rather not anything
and if you have a legal question or your
constituents come to you with a legal
question we really do want to be a
resource and are happy to um help in any
way that may be useful um I won't
reiterate the testimony just we are
strongly in opposition to this bill I
sent our testimony from our Board of
Governors um to to the house education
committee this morning as well as a
Tracker a national tracker on covid-19
related lawsuits um happening throughout
the country important to note there have
been zero lawsuits related to covid
filed in New Hampshire to date that we
know of um as um the Deputy Commissioner
for the Department of Labor noted there
has been one um covid related workers
comp claim it's important to note that
business do pay workers comp insurance
so that does not cost the B when a claim
is filed for workers comp it does not
cost the business additionally um and I
believe that um successful workers comp
claim was from a hospital worker so that
just makes sense to me as someone that
plays an attorney not someone who's a
practicing
attorney um one more thing I'd like to
note is this and just want to emphasize
the way this bill is written and I think
the attorneys did a great job of noting
that the liability St or the standard
raised to a knowing act um I'm happy to
send the committee sample liability
policies that are regulated um by the
industry across across the country um
that generally exclude knowing acts so
just trying to you know dumb it down
from some legal jargon um as I try to do
every day in my job The Knowing act if
if
if a claim were brought to the standards
set out in this bill which again they
probably won't because it would be
impossible to prove nearly impossible to
prove unless it was totally
egregious an insurance comp an
insurance um insurance company who
represents or covers a small business
would point to The Knowing act and say
this is the language in your policy we
won't cover you from this you're on the
hook for defending this yourself this
bill does not as written would not help
small businesses it would actually help
insurance companies um so happy to
answer any questions provide any or
gather any more information that may be
helpful to the committee and um thank
you very much for your time and
consideration sure thank you very much
questions from the
committee see none I thank you for
sticking around thank you Chase okay
last um person to testify is David prer
and I believe you're with the Bia
correct that is correct uh for the
record I'm David ker director of public
policy at the business and industry
Association of New Hampshire uh we are
in strong support of this bill um and
we're not alone uh we recently sent a
letter to policy leaders uh urging the
passage of some sort of Safe Harbor
legislation and co-signed on that were
nearly three dozen other chambers of
Commerce and uh trade associations
around the state um I want to clear up
some I think misconceptions about the
bill uh as is written and as we read it
um these Safe Harbor protections uh an
important limitation on these is that
they really only protect businesses that
are following state and federal
guidelines in good faith so it's not a
blanket immunity uh it won't protect uh
Bad actors in You businesses who are not
following those guidelines and we don't
believe that it should cover those um
you know if you aren't doing everything
you can to help us prevent the spread of
covid-19 during this pandemic then you
should be held accountable for that um
but you know
99.99999% of businesses out there uh
really are following all of the
guidelines as best as uh you know
possible um so this would help protect
them against loss suits uh from a number
of third parties who would possibly
claim that they contracted covid-19 at
that
business uh I you know I've heard it
several times today that well we haven't
had any of these filed in New Hampshire
so it's not a problem well we shouldn't
wait for it to become a problem before
making this legislation we should do
this now to prevent it from ever
becoming a problem in the first place uh
you know if those I think it was
mentioned I think someone said uh 400
lawsuits filed around the country
already uh you know if those are
starting to become successful it is
undoubtedly going to come uh to New
Hampshire as well um we also heard some
testimony that uh
businesses aren't worried about this I'm
telling you uh as the viia all of our
members are worried about this this is
one of the top concerns uh that we are
hearing from our members uh both large
and small you know uh 70% of our members
MERS have an annual payroll of $3
million or less we have a lot of small
businesses as members as well and they
are also uh you know explaining how much
of an issue this could be for them in
fact we've started to hear or we've
heard a story about a business um last
year that when businesses started to
reopen they said that they weren't going
to reopen and part of that reason was
because they were afraid that they could
get sued which would just put them out
of business anyway um additionally we've
heard that uh it would be a pretty tough
case to uh win in court anyway but it's
kind of also important to realize that
any business who is defending itself in
one of these lawsuits that's 3040
$50,000 and the fact that it would be
difficult to prove is also just
Testament to how difficult this case
would be if it were to go to trial which
means it would be a long Discovery
process there would be a lot involved
and it would just be an expensive uh
mess to try and deal with and further
along those same lines we've heard that
this would only protect the insurance
companies or benefit the insurance
companies uh what we're hearing is that
insurance policies a lot of times more
often than not have exceptions for
communicable diseases and so insurance
would not cover the legal fees no matter
what um the statute said uh because of
these exceptions for communicable
diseases and therefore you're Le your
small businesses or you know any
business and you know obviously I'm with
Bia so I represent businesses other
Enterprises hospitals but you know this
would also affect anywhere where the
public gathers you're talking um
municipalities schools they all have
this same concern but they'd be on the
hook for these legal uh fees um and one
more note that I just want to make is
that if the um business is being sued
let's say that their claim uh even if
it's just a prade litigant and they're
saying okay you know I want $220,000 in
um
in medical expenses damages medical
expenses well now the business has to
weigh okay do I just give this person
$20,000 or do I spend the 30 40 50,000
to defend myself uh so yeah they might
not win but it might actually be more
efficient for the business to settle and
that would also be a large problem
that's a lot of resources that the
business business is now spending on
defending itself against lawsuits rather
than hiring back their employees
reinvesting in their business trying to
recover from their lost revenues as a
result of this co uh Corona virus
pandemic so it's really vitally
important that we get bills with these
Safe Harbor Provisions passed so that we
can recover this economy try and move on
past this pandemic and with that I will
conclude my testimony I know it's been a
long day already uh so please if you
have any questions I'm happy to answer
thank you very much I do see a question
from representative Cornell hi U thank
you for taking my question um would it
be true and I hope it wouldn't be that
if businesses knew that they couldn't be
sued for this would they might maybe not
be as careful or put as many safeguards
in as they as they
could
just uh thank you for the question and
it's a great question uh because we
heard that this would just insulate
businesses entirely uh no they they
would absolutely be taking every
precaution they can um for many reasons
not only just because of the lawsuits
but uh you know businesses are putting
precautions in and to try and help
prevent the spread of covid-19 for
reasons one if they have a bunch of
people sick with covid-19 they can't run
their business without employees so they
want to help uh prevent the spread of
covid-19 for that um two uh obviously
there are State fin
if you are not following uh the
guidelines and also finally related back
to the lawsuits this statute would only
protect you if you're following the
guidelines so if that business was even
with this law if that business isn't
following the guidelines well then they
don't benefit from the statute and they
protected thank you um representative
Hopson has a question on leave yes I do
um thank you for taking my question can
you explain to me where um Chambers of
Commerce they they are not 501 c3s I
think they are
50136 is that correct or yeah they're
501 c6s yeah could you could you tell me
um if if they would fall under these
Provisions do you know yes let me I just
want to make sure the L language is what
I believe it is yeah so um under this uh
statute it says business meets an
organization or enterprising entity
engaged in commercial industrial
professional activities uh businesses
may be for-profit entities or nonprofit
organizations uh 501 c6s are still
considered nonprofits so they should be
um able to qualify under this as well
all right thank you very much you're
welcome thank you any further
questions see none I thank you very much
thank
you this point we can close the hearing
on
H5 I think sorry there's hand
raised yeah there is I don't know Roger
I don't have this person schedule so I'm
not
sure
typically bring okay you know what I'm
talk yes Mr J um had uh just about
closing the hearing but uh give you a
minute uh under understood thank you
thank you so much uh I thought M Marissa
Chase had put me on the speaker line for
the New Hampshire Association for
justice I am a governor at large of the
board so if you'd permit me a minute or
two I would that would be appreciated if
not I understand
okay I I what I wanted to do was I I
wanted to thank uh representative Miler
for his question and to drill down on
that a little bit his question to
representative Pedra had to do with is
there a definition of what negligence is
and you heard a lot about you know
reasonableness and whatnot let me make
that even easier every Jury has received
an instruction from the judge defining
negligence and it appears in every
appell at case in New Hampshire
negligence is the failure to do what a
reasonable person would do under the
circumstances or doing something that a
reasonable person or business would not
do under the circumstances obviously
that changes with the circumstances now
based on that definition there are
really two issues that that come out of
that and come out of this bill one is
the bill would send a mixed message
about what's reason able and the other
is it would create a race to the bottom
mixed messages we have the CDC we have
the governor we have our own Bureau for
the Bureau of Infectious Disease Control
putting out guidelines telling
businesses what to do in every Court in
every case for bodily injury those
guidelines would be the definition of
what a reasonable business would do
under the circumstances at the time
those guidelines were in force that
would be the definition of what's
reasonable and therefore what's
negligent this statute says oh but not
withstanding that as long as you're not
grossly negligent you cannot be held
liable so we're telling them the
governor and the CDC are given them
guidelines on one hand but on the other
hand you don't have to comply with them
because that's just negligence that's
not gross negligence you can't be held
responsible do we want to create a
system of mixed messages like that where
the CDC guidance and our Bureau of
infectious control guidance is basically
a waste of time comined with that is the
race to the bottom most of our
businesses want to do the reasonable
thing but there's always a cost of doing
business of taking more reasonable
precautions there's always going to be a
motivation for some few businesses to
save a few bucks by cutting back a
little bit on some of those guidelines
on some of the precautions they are
taking being not as careful as the CDC
or the governor want them to be and
guess what that puts them at a
competitive advantage AG over the
reasonable businesses reasonable
businesses feel the pressure to do the
same thing and there's suddenly a race
to the bottom of taking fewer and fer
precautions so that they can pass on
their their savings to their customers
and keep their customers and keep their
business and we would never get to the
point where things are so bad that it's
gross negligence that I could prove and
pursue a case so those are just a couple
of the reasons why the nhj opposed this
Bill thank you for your time I'd be
happy answer questions if you still have
any let's see around the
room I do not see
any thank you very much for uh thank you
for giving me the two minutes thank you
I appreciate it thank you great thank
you um and with with that I think we're
finished with
else h255 and uh give the virtual gel
the thank you very much represent fi for
taking over that last bill appreciate it
and you did a good job uh I would like
to um we're at 3:15 now and I am going
to have an executive session right now
on HB 513
that's relative to degree granting
authority of Signum University and
relative to the authority of the higher
education commission I recognize
representative Howard for a
motion thank you Mr chairman uh I would
be happy to make a motion with regards
to House Bill 513 I would move that this
bill ought to
pass and representative Cordell you
second it motion made by represent
Allard and second by representa cordelli
discussion from the
sponsor represent alard do you have a
few comments or you can pass on that if
you want um I would just say briefly uh
this uh this
bill as I I stated in in the originally
this bill is the Resurgence of an idea
that began more than a year ago uh and
came to us uh and uh
in my opinion should have passed at that
time but it couldn't uh so it's been
resurrected and it's a bill whose Time
Has Come
uh it's time for the citizens of New
Hampshire to have access uh to degrees
from Signum
University do the second care
to offer any thank you um yes I would
just add that uh uh this been kicking
around for a year or so um we had
testimony uh just the other day from uh
the Department of
Education Mr applebe that the higher
commission
has sign Signum um and the ball is now
an artport the Signum has uh satisfied
uh many if not all of the original 13
items that they were to
pursue um so I think that there is no
reason uh to not
grant them we granting Authority and
pass this
legislation thank you very much is there
any further
discussion represent R uh thank you Mr
chair I'm disappointed that this is
coming before right now you had
indicated in our last last committee
meeting that you would uh consult with
the elite ranking Dem for executive
sessions this has not been uh I've been
not consulted with on this at all so I'm
disappointed Mr chair that you did not
follow through on your commitment to do
that in particular in relation to this
particular bill this has been around for
some time for a good reason and that is
are serious questions about the veracity
of this bill and the leadership of this
University this in my nine years I have
never been threatened by somebody who
was trying to pursue a bill I've been
lobbied no question about that but as uh
we heard in the the last hearing that
had this representative luno basically
read a letter in which the president of
the College University I'll say college
uh
threatened directly Mr luno and
indirectly
me to me the veracity of doing that says
something about the university and its
integrity and on that and on on that
basis
alone this should not go forward because
frankly I don't think we need
institutions of Higher Learning in this
state that basically threaten
Representatives because of their
position on a particular bill I will be
voting a strong no on this
recommendation thank you
thank you very much represent represent
leas yes looking at that letter I am not
sure how
saying you have publicly printed things
that um were Incorrect and rather than
going to the Cress
to uh reu these things that were printed
I would like to meet with you in person
to work this out so that you you know so
that um
I'd like to interject for a second here
we are dealing with HB
513 the authority of sign granting
authority of singam University to be
authorized by this legislature yes and I
don't believe the discussion of where
we're going has anything to do with the
nature of the bill which simply says
approved by the higher education
commission and
authorized five those the only changes
so let's stick to the content please I
was just trying to say that I don't
think that constitutes criminal
threatening and therefore
doesn't that has absolutely nothing to
do with this content on this bill so
discussion yes rep wock thank you uh Mr
chairman uh I had to dig out my file I
was surprised this came up without any
notice today at all even during the
lunch break so we could prepare but that
being said um I was inclined to support
this uh bill I have been inclined last
year although I didn't because I thought
the higher education and doe done their
due diligence of course we saw all the
the uh items that had not been corrected
but supposedly are corrected now um but
I became concerned last year uh as I am
now when both times we asked the
president of the University uh what he
did with students who had paid their
money uh for a program to get their
masters uh and the University was not
certified for that and as a matter of
fact one of the speakers uh an eloquent
speaker actually for in his favor came
on both years and and said she got the
degree and actually got her adjunct job
because of that but at both times the
school was not certified um to give
degrees so I I feel like it's been a uh
the first year I understand that we knew
but last year knowing that they
continued to take students money uh with
the hope and assumption that they get a
Ms uh for the course work and that that
concerns me uh the other part that that
that significantly concerns me actually
um I think it's kind of unfair on the
other hand I guess if people are willing
enough to know that they're going to pay
their money to take a tuition course and
not have no valid it's their money they
loss so I guess that's that's where it
is but but I do think it was uh a little
shabby of the institution to do that
thank you very much are there further Is
there further test uh
discussion not seeing a request for
further discussion on have the clerk
call the rooll
please this is on House 53 can you all
hear
me yes I can can make out
there can you hear
me
representative Corelli
yes representative bone yes represent Al
yes representative leakas yes
representative M
Andress yes
she we can't see her
face I'm sorry
okay
Oliver yes thank you representa Leon yes
represent s
yeses
no
repr
coming representative Sean no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Ellison no
representative Mullen no representative
yes 11 yay eight
y Mr chair yes uh can you answer my
question as far as
working with the ranking Democrat to
deal with the issue
of issues that are going to come before
this committee as far as exec sessions I
have put in the calendar the exec
sessions which are are set for next week
and the following week I don't know if
it's been published for the following
week but that left only two that haven't
been that won't be posted and that this
is one of the two and yes we did we do
notice in the calendar that exec session
may follow uh any time during the the
hearing process so um that that's the
way this is happening today so your your
your answer is no my answer is that we
just did exactly what is in the calendar
and allowed the by rules to occur so the
answer is no thank you very
much be minority rep Minority Report yes
uh either representative luno or Miler
would do that Minority Report thank
you represent luno was not present at
the vote then I will do it thank you
you're
welcome so that uh Mr Mr chairman yes
just a point of clarification uh in the
future if you're going to call an
executive session and there is a lunch
bake before that executive session could
you at least give us the courtesy of
acknowledging that
so everyone have a chance to
prepare instead of throwing on the last
minute my advice is that after we have
hearings
it's you ought to be preparing for the
exact session which can occur at any
time however the exact sessions which we
have scheduled in the calendar those
exact sessions cannot occur prior to the
scheduled times so I believe there's
only one bill left that we have heard
that's not
schedu that would yeah they just voted
on Mr chair Mr chair I'm not concerned
about the
upep I'm just asking is the courtesy if
you at least to notify us that you're
going to do things at least if we have a
break of lunch hour so we can compare
that's all I understand the generic
framing in the Bill thank you I'm gonna
follow the rules that have been set up
for our functioning here so that just be
prepared for any uh Bill to be exact uh
I understand the rules Mr chairman I
just ask for
Courtesy thank you very
much okay we are at en closure of what
we're doing today uh so at this point in
time I'm adjourning and closing down the
session for today thank
you